hey this is andrew brown your cloud
instructor at exam pro and i'm bringing
you another complete study course and
this time it's the microsoft security
compliance and identity fundamentals
made available to you here on
freecodecamp so
this course is designed to help you pass
and achieve microsoft issued
certification
and the way we're going to do that is
via lots of lecture content
and cheat sheets so on the day your exam
you have a high chance of passing
so you can put that uh certification on
your resume
or linkedin to prove you have that azure
security knowledge and get that cloud
job or
that promotion you've been looking for
so just a bit about me
i'm previously the cto of multiple
edtech companies with 15 years industry
experience
five years specializing cloud i'm an aws
community hero
i published many many free cloud courses
just like this one
and i love star trek and coconut water
so if you ever meet me and know what to
buy me for a drink
i just want to take a moment here to say
thank you to viewers like you because
it's you that
make these cloud courses possible if
you're looking for ways to support
more free cloud courses just like this
one the best way to do that is to
buy our additional study materials at
exam pro dot co
for this course in particular it's
forward slash sc 900
and here you're going to get study notes
flash cards quizlets
downloadable lectures downloadable cheat
sheets
practice exams and you can even ask
questions and get some learning support
if you want to know what courses are
coming up
next uh the best way is to follow me on
twitter i love
hearing when people have passed their
exam or what you want to see next for a
free cloud certification course
so there we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are at the start of our journey
asking the most important question which
is what is the sc900
so it's the microsoft security
compliance and identity fundamentals and
it provides broad knowledge across
microsoft security services
so the certification will demonstrate a
person can define and understand
the xero trust model microsoft privacy
m365
defender and azure defender azure active
directory
and a broad overview of microsoft and
m365 security services
and the certification is generally
referred to by its course code the sc900
and it's an essential certification no
matter your azure path
this course in particular is very
lecture heavy and greatly involves azure
active directory so that is something we
can look forward to
this is an easy course to pass and great
for those new to security and compliance
so
here's my azure road map and there's a
lot more azure certifications but we
just kept the ones on the board that
actually are relevant to our
possible paths and so here is some
suggestions i have for you and the first
thing is that you definitely want to
take the ac 900 first
the sc 900 while being a fundamental
certification
is much longer than these other ones and
how has a lot of information so
it makes it a little bit more digestible
if you take the az900 first
if you're taking a general pass such as
the administrator developer onto your
solutions architect
or devops engineer this is going to
really make it easier at the associate
and expert level
especially for the administrator because
this particular
certification has a lot to do with azure
active directory
now of course the security
certifications which should be the
primary reason why you want to
take this path and azure has four at the
associate level
this is the reason why we don't really
do any lab content follow-alongs
within the fundamental course because if
we did we'd just be
uh making these courses because if you
were to look into the exam guides for
all these four certifications
uh you're just going to be seeing the
same information but
us applying that knowledge and saying
okay how do we do this for real
okay so how long does it take to sta how
long
should you study to pass the
certification well if you have one years
of azure experience you're looking about
six hours
if you've passed your az 900 you're
looking about 12 hours if you're
completely new so
you're not taking the ac 900 going
straight for it you're looking at 20
hours
okay this one is a longer than any of
the other fundamental certifications
and i recommend about 30 minutes a day
for 14
days all right just keep it within the
scope of two weeks if you can
so where do you take this exam well you
can do it in person
at a test center or online from the
convenience of your own home so there
are two
different uh data test centers that are
partnered with uh microsoft
and azure to deliver these the one is
psi or pearson vue
they both have in person and online uh i
strongly recommend that you always do in
person because it's a more controlled
environment it's less stressful you
don't have to worry about the internet
going out
uh or some other issue that might occur
and so these are proctored exams that
means that there's a supervisor somebody
monitoring your progress as you take the
certification
uh so that you aren't uh cheating or
things like that
so what does it take to pass this exam
well you gotta watch the lecture videos
do you generally have to do hands-on
labs for this one i'm going to cross
this out because basically there's next
to none in this course
so uh you know it's more so watching the
lecture videos
you probably would like to get some paid
online practice exams and if you do need
one go to exampro.com and that's a great
way to support these free courses that's
how i'm able to make
these for you at no cost okay for the
content outline
the breakdown is describe the concepts
of security compliance and identity
describe the capabilities of
microsoft identity and access management
solutions describe the capabilities of
microsoft security solutions
describe the capabilities of the
microsoft compliant solutions and we
will open up the exam guide in the next
video here just to give you a more clear
view what the contents of the course
is for grading you have to get at least
70 percent to pass so around that
because it's using scaled scoring
the response types uh we're looking at
here well first of all if there's 40 to
60 questions so you
can get about 12 to 18 questions wrong
some questions are worth more than one
points
there is no penalty for wrong questions
some questions cannot be skipped
and the format of questions could be
multiple choice multiple answer drag and
drop
hot area or case studies the duration of
the course just like all the fundamental
certifications is one hour
so you roughly get about a minute per
question uh the exam time is 60 minutes
but your seat time is 90 minutes so your
seat time refers the amount of
time you should allocate for the exam so
this could include the time to review
instructions
read and accept the nda complete the
exam provide feedback at the end
and this certification well i normally
say two uh two years because that's
pretty much the standard
but any fundamental certification just
never expires and i didn't put this in
my other fundamental videos because i
did not know that
but apparently once you have it you have
it forever so that's a pretty good
benefit there so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and what i've done here is opened up uh
the page where we can find the exam
guide outline so you have to type in
sc900
certification it should bring it to this
page you scroll on down to your skills
measured
and you download the outline now at the
top of these documents this is a very
new certification
it's not even a year old from the time
i'm making this but
a lot of times you'll see red text in
this document the top it'll say there
has been changes
and it scares people because they think
that maybe the course is out of date
but i'm going to tell you that unless
they change the number here unless it
becomes the sc901 or 902
this course is going to be mostly
relevant
okay because they're only ever making my
new changes they're never going to
change
huge sections of a course if they do
then they're going to update the numbers
so that's how you know whether my course
is
still relevant or not okay is whether
the course number changes not if there's
red text
but going down below here we'll just
quickly go through some of these
sections and some of the thoughts i have
about this course so
we have the zero trust methodology is
the first thing they want to learn
xero trust model is super important it's
the foundation of this entire course and
ties over to azure active directory
so you're definitely going to know that
inside and out
the shared responsibility model which we
covered in the az900 nothing has changed
there
defense and depth that's like a seven
layer thing not super important common
threats which are going to lay the
foundation for some
other services um encryption which is
pretty straightforward
stuff we covered in the az-104 the
microsoft privacy principles
this is a bit confusing because they
have two different pages but i cover
both of them here so you know both of
them
the service trust portal where we can
download audit reports
so that's a very simple thing there
primary security perimeter this is a
concept
of the zero trust model really should be
up in the top section there
author authentication authorization ipd
so identity providers think facebook
google linkedin
twitter uh active directory which is a
huge component of this course federated
services
identity attacks uh and so then we have
um the notice here it says service
identities for azure id capabilities of
azure id
management capabilities of azure id
ident identity
protection and governance capabilities
of azure id so there's a lot
of azure ad stuff a good
chunk of this is actually covered in the
az-104 so if you're taking that
as your natural path like basically like
half of this at least half of this
is covered is actually the contents
coming from there okay
so that's going to be really great for
you going down below here
now we're into microsoft capability i
guess it still says azure so nsgs ddos
azure firewall bastion
web application firewall azure azure
encryption data
a lot of this covered again in the
az-104 so it was very easy
easy for me to bring this over
simplified it more to a business use
case for you okay
the azure security center azure security
score um azure defender
cloud security posture management and
there's a lot of these terms
uh like a lot of initialisms and we go
thoroughly through them in the uh
primer i actually uh squeezed in a
primer a security primer in the front of
this course
because uh they just lack a lot of that
information to uh
help you understand the stuff and so i
just did that to round out the entire
course overall
so you have azure sentinel where you
have siems soars and xtrs
then there's microsoft 365 defender and
there's a lot of stuff with defender
because there's azure defender and 365
defender and there's all these sub
services there's unbelievable amount of
stuff in here so identity office 365
endpoints cloud app security
then you have the microsoft 365 security
center so you have a security score
there reports dashboards things like
that
that's actually how you access azure
azure defenders through the
m365 or sorry through the um
security center and then through uh
my m365 defender it's through uh well
actually just go to the security panel
that's how you get to it
you have microsoft intune that's for
managing remote devices
that's part of microsoft endpoint
manager
so you can remotely control or or
have security over devices tablets and
computers
then we have here um uh
the microsoft compliance solution so
there's the microsoft um
or m365 compliance center and there's a
ton of stuff in this course like tons
and tons
i would say like a good quarter of this
entire well it says 25 here but
25 percent of the course is all about
the compliance center there's tons of
stuff in here for that
and actually that's the end of the
course so yeah it's mostly azure id
and the compliance center a handful of
azure uh
services and a bunch of marketing
resources
okay so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are starting our journey for the
sc900 talking about zero trust
methodologies or the zero trust model in
particular
and this is super important because it
really lays the foundation of the way we
should be thinking about
uh all of the security that we're gonna
be doing within azure and actually in
any
cloud service providers because the xero
trust model is really
uh what is being adopted today and we'll
talk about why that is
so the zero trust model operates on the
principles of trust no one and verify
everything so if you have malicious
actors
and they're being able to bypass
conventional access controls and
demonstrates traditional security
measures
that's no longer sufficient we need to
come up with a new way
to protect ourselves and so that's where
azure or microsoft in particular has
come up with their
version of a zero trust model called the
microsoft's zero truss model
and this is based on three principles
and six pillars so
in the three principles we have verified
explicitly uh least privileged access
assume breach for our six pillars we
have um identities
endpoints uh an easier way of thinking
about endpoints is just think of them as
devices
apps data infrastructure and networks
and i would say that if you wanted to
put an emphasis on anything it's going
to be identities
which comes down to azure ad that seems
to be
the largest focus here in this entire
course and to really ensuring the zero
trust
methodology works the xero trust model
is not unique to microsoft gcp has its
own
zero trust model aws has its own zero
trust model but the one here is just
going to really work for azure
okay
[Music]
okay so let's review the three
principles we said that are in the
microsoft zero trust model
the first is verify explicity and so
this always authenticates and authorizes
based on all the available data points
um the next one is lease privilege
access so limit user access with just in
time and just enough access
for risk-based adaptive policies and
data protection assume breach so
minimize blast radius and segment access
verify end-to-end encryption and use
analytics to gain visibility drive
threat detection and improve defenses
now you see me highlighting things in
red
and i'm not telling you what they are
because we have a whole section on these
things so don't worry
if you see a bunch of terms and you're
just getting overwhelmed uh we're going
to cover them multiple times
and so you just understand that we're
going to front load you with a lot of
terms you don't know
but you will know them by the end this
course okay
[Music]
all right so let's take a look here at
the six pillars for the microsoft zero
trust
model starting with the most important
one identities
and this verifies and secures each
identity with strong authentication
across your entire
digital estate and so for each of these
pillars we're going to talk about some
of the related services i'm not going to
describe what they do
because we're definitely going to be
covering them all in this course in
great
detail but i want you to get some
exposure so you see all these names
again and again and again okay so the
first is iam
the next one is azure active directory
and this one gets a lot of attention in
this course they might as well call this
the azure active directory security
course
we have single sign-on mfa password list
authentication which is a subset of mfa
risk-based policies identity secure
score and you'll see like three
different types of secure score
in this course so something that is very
useful uh throughout
microsoft and azure we have endpoints
and it's easy to think of these as
devices because
their endpoints are used to gain
visibility into devices accessing the
network
ensuring compliance and health status
before granting access
the endpoint is what grants access for
this we have
azure ad device manager to register our
devices with our identity provider
generally the the controls underneath
which is
mobile device management and mobile
application management is managed by
intune
and this service is now actually part of
microsoft endpoint manager
uh and if we want to get a protection
around our endpoints then we have
microsoft defender for endpoints
but we got defender for everything in
this course and you'll see that soon
enough
then you have dlps uh so data loss
prevention policies so we do not lose
our data
so that we like it does not just get
disclosed and we can keep our data
our sensitive data protected right for
apps we have
discover shadow i.t so ensure
appropriate in-app permissions
gate access based on real-time analytics
and monitor control user actions
so there for this we have policy-based
access controls
we can use the microsoft cloud app
security azure ad application proxy
cloud discovery or i suppose that could
have been e-discovery
there's definitely a spelling mistake
there so i think it's just supposed to
be cloud discovery
um we have just in time virtual machine
access onto the last three pillars
we have data so move from perimeter
based data protection to data driven
protection
use intelligence to classify and label
data encrypt and restrict access based
on organizational pr
policies so here we can use sensitive
sensitivity labels
microsoft information protection data
classification azure
uh information protection so aip scanner
decision based policies and data loss
prevention
all of this stuff is in the microsoft
the if you're doing it on the microsoft
side it's the
m3s can i type text in here no i can't
but it's the m365 compliance center this
is where all this stuff comes into play
uh we'll see later on so infrastructure
used telemetry to detect
attacks and anomalies automatically
block and flag risk behaviors and employ
least privileged access principles so
here we can use the azure security
center
azure ad manager identities user and
resource segmentation
v-nets peering rules privilege identity
management
nsgs asgs azure firewall microsoft
defender for endpoint microsoft defender
for identity
azure sentinel on the last one here is
network
i hate doing networking but it's a core
to cloud you know so
ensure devices and users aren't trusted
just because they're on an internal
network encrypt all internal
communications limit access by policy
and employ micro segmentation real-time
threat detection so here we can do
network segmentation azure ddos
production service
azure firewall the laugh vpns proxies
bastions ssl tls and so there you go
that is all the pillars
so we just defined what the xero trust
uh model is and that's fine and dandy
but how do we go ahead and start
implementing it well they have a nice
tool
that can get us started here called the
zero trust assessment tool and this is a
free tool to assess your organization's
degree of adoption towards the zero
trust model and suggest
to improve your current security
implementations so it's
basically a bunch of questions across
the six pillars and then it'll give you
a recommendations now we just ran over
the six pillars and i actually went
through this and extracted them all out
for you so you basically just saw all of
them from the tool
but uh if you want to uh see more
detailed steps
uh that will be really useful okay
[Music]
i wanted to take a moment to actually
show you the assessment tool because
it's really easy to use you don't even
need an account
so all i did was i typed in xero trust
assessment tool microsoft and
i was brought to here and what the what
you want to do here is just start at the
beginning and we have identities and
lastly some questions like
have you enabled mfa authentication for
internal users
so i'll say some users because some of
my users might not be
good about it which forms of password
list authentication are enabled
so password list means you don't have to
enter a password in
so maybe we have phone call text phone
microsoft authenticator i definitely use
502 security keys we'll go next which of
your user groups are provisioned with
single sign-on
and like does anyone use it so maybe my
customers are using single sign-on
which of the following security policy
engines are using to make access
decisions for enterprise resources
and if you don't know any of these names
then you wouldn't check box them i know
mobile device management so we'll do
that
have you disabled legacy authentication
i'm not sure what they mean here but
maybe you have like an old system that's
not part of
you're not using azure id so it'd say
yeah maybe i'm still using a legacy
system i haven't migrated to the cloud
yet
are you using real-time user and sign in
risk detection to evaluate request
access
if you're using azure id and you have it
turned on you'd know but we'll say no
for using a legacy system
once the following technologies have you
integrated with your identity access
management solution
if you're again a small company you
might have not done much or maybe you've
only done mobile device management
that's usually one that's pretty common
which of the following context is used
for access policies
um so like access policies like access
to things so what is the context
and i would say most people are going to
be doing the user like what user is
allowed to use it
and a lot of these are never ever
thought about so we'll go next
are you using identity security score
for guidance um actually i do but
let's just say you said no and so the
idea here is we'll get our results
and it'll give you like instructions so
this is where i extracted out all these
little details for you
in the slides there so you have to go
through it but it describes it
multi-factor
helps you protect your applications by
requiring requiring users to confirm the
identity etc etc
so explains them all right you could
just answer no and everything and it'll
give you all the information at the end
and it's very useful to read through
this and and uh to understand it but
again we cover this through the whole
course so
you don't have to read it here you just
gotta follow along okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at azure's shared
responsibility model
all the cloud service providers have a
shared responsibility model they're more
or less the same
um and so this is just to tell you like
what you are responsible for and what
azure is responsible for
this is covered in the az104 the az204
and the az900 and definitely we need to
cover this again even if you know it we
should go over it again
uh for the sc900 so that we can think in
the context of security
so for responsibilities we have
information data devices
account identities identity directories
applications network controls operating
system
physical host physical network physical
data center and then we have
saas paas iaas
and on premise if you forget those terms
the first is software as a service the
software that
uses that you use in the cloud so think
365. so
word doc excel skype uh onedrive
sharepoint dynamics crm you know if
if imagine just all-purpose software but
you access it via the cloud
then you have platform as a service so
deploy apps without worrying about the
underlying infrastructure so
azure app services you just have an app
you put it up there it just works
infrastructure is a service so the basic
building blocks of cloud i.t so storage
compute databases networking i call that
the core4 uh you should always know that
no matter what cloud service provider
you're using
on premise so data center owned and
operated maintained by the customer
so we'll do is just show you the blocks
here and the blue
represents the customer's responsibility
okay
i i know it's like you think like
blue would be for azure but they made it
blue and i should have really
i should have really um put a legend on
this because i always get confused by
that as well
but we're going to just do that and this
is the customer okay
so going down below here look at
physical host networks and data center
so azure is going to take responsibility
if you're using ias
pas or sas azure takes responsibility
for all the physical stuff
and there's a lot of work there if you
had to secure that stuff
now once you get you go up a bit more so
if you're using
an operating system at the pass or sas
level you're still responsible
or sir azure will take more
responsibility here
um but you know that's generally broadly
how this works but if we just kind of
break it down into three major
categories i'm just going to clear our
board here it's getting a little bit
messy so
and this this lines up to these lines i
just didn't have lines in here
but the idea here is this this is always
the responsibility of the customer
everything above here this is going to
vary per service type the second tier
and the bottom there the responsibility
transfers by
the cloud providers okay a few caveats
here is that regardless of the type of
deployment the following response
responsibilities are always retained by
you so data endpoints
account access management so just
remember those four there at the end
okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at defense and
depth and so there are seven layers of
security that azure wants you to know
a kind of maps up to the shared
responsibility model
a lot of times we see these things when
um
organizations or or cloud providers are
talking about
their security centers like the actual
data centers and how they're secured
but this is more general it doesn't
necessarily have to apply to
a data center but uh let's go and work
our way through
inside out okay so the core we have data
so access to business and customer data
encryption
to protect our data then we have
applications so
applications secure and and free of
security vulnerabilities
then you have compute so access to vms
ports on premise and cloud
the network limit communications between
resources using segmentation and access
controls
the perimeter so distribute denials of
service protection
to filter large-scale attacks before
they can cause the denial service for
users
identity and access so control uh
controlling access to infrastructure
and change controls and then you have
physical security so limiting access to
a data center to only authorize
personnel so
the idea is that if you really want to
like if you want to get to data you got
to go through all these steps here these
are all the
layers of defense um and so i just want
to give extra emphasis to
um this one here identity and access
because
this one's like the besides the physical
security
this one's the outermost one so they
they will say like
your your your perimeter like the modern
perimeter is defined based on your i
like your identity okay and we'll see
that more here in this course
hey it's andrew brown from exam bro
we're looking at the cia triad
and that stands for confidentiality
integrity and availability
and this model is used for describing
the foundation to security principles
and their trade-offs and relationships
and so
just to look at it here quickly so we
have confidentiality so
is a component of privacy that
implements to protect our data from
unauthorized viewers
and practices can be using cryptographic
keys to encrypt our data
and using keys to encrypt our keys so
known as envelope encryption
you have integrity so maintaining
ensuring the accuracy and completeness
of your data over its entire life cycle
and practice utilizing asset compliant
databases for valid transactions
utilizing tamper tamper evident or
tamper proof
uh hardware security modules so hsms or
availability information needs to be
made available when needed
so in practice you want things to be
highly available you want to
mitigate ddos attacks you want to uh
have decryption
access that looks like there's a spell
of mistake here something looks funny
there but
um the ca model was or triad was first
mentioned in the nist publication in
1977
there have been efforts to expand and
modernize or suggest alternatives to the
cia triad
because it is really old right so one
was like in 1998 where we have the six
atomic elements of information so
confidence
confidentiality possession integrity
authentication availability utility
and then 2004 we have this engineering
principles for
information technology security um and
they that
that has like 33 security principles so
um the thing with this triad is that you
kind of get like a trade-off they say
like if you go and full of
confidentiality you might have to make
compromises here or there
um to what degree i don't know but this
is a very
well-known model and so it's just good
for you to know it okay
[Music]
let's talk about common threats and
these are in particular what azure wants
you to know there's definitely a lot
more than just four here
but these are the four main ones that
azure wants you to focus on
before we talk about let's just say what
is a threat so a threat in cloud
security is
a potential negative action or event
facilitated by the vulnerability that
results in an unwanted impact
to a computer system or application
and so as you're watching you know the
following four types so the first is a
dictionary tax so attackers attempt to
steal
identity by brute forcing into a target
account
by enumerating over a large number of
known passwords
and i actually put the word enumerating
in there because it's very common to see
this when you are doing uh pen testing
enumeration is very common uh but
throughout the entire course i never saw
them ever use that term so i figured hey
i'll insert it there so you get to see
it
disruptive attack so an attack which
attempts to disrupt a computer system or
computer network
for various reasons so that could be
ddos coin miners root kits
trojans worms ransomware a type of
malicious software
that when installed holds data
workstations are
a network hostage until a ransom has
been paid we've heard of entire
like cities being ransomed you know what
i mean like the mayor has to pay some
person
somewhere to to get something back you
know data breach so when a malicious
actor gains
unauthorized access to a system in order
to extract private data
so those are the core four threats they
want you to know okay
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're looking at the concept of
vulnerabilities
so a vulnerability is a whole or
weakness in the application that can
beat
a design flaw or implementation bug that
allows an attacker to cause harm to
stakeholders or an application
the term is used throughout the sc900
course but they never describe it so
here i'm describing it for you
and i've actually pulled up a bunch of
vulnerabilities from owasp owps is the
open web application security project
if you're in security you want to know
what oh wasp is they have a lot of cool
things there
but i just got their big old list here
so here's a big list
and this is application focused uh but
there's some that you might have seen
before like buffer
overflow you've heard of stack overflow
that's kind of what they're talking
about there
take advantage of memory leaks lease
privilege violation so
this is a very very common one where um
the privileges aren't strict enough and
that's where they can escalate their
privileges
uh or maybe we have like using a broken
or risky cryptographic algorithm
maybe like instead of using uh shaw you
should be using b crypt things like that
uh you know but i just want you to
fundamentally understand what a
vulnerability is it's a whole or
weakness in an
application okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at encryption and to
understand this we need to know what
cryptography is
so this is the practice and study of
techniques for secure communication in
the presence of third parties
which we'll call adversaries and so
encryption is the process of encoding
so scrambling information using a key
and cipher
to store sensitive data in an
unintelligible format
as a means of protection an encryption
takes in plain text
and produces a cipher text um
and so a very famous example of an
encryption machine was the enigma
machine used during world war ii
uh and the idea was that you'd have to
get a daily key and this would set the
position of the rotors
and these rotors would determine what
ciphers would be substituted for that
day
all right
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we were just looking at encryption
and we saw the word cipher so i want to
dive in and describe what that is so a
cipher is an algorithm that performs
encryption or decryption
and cipher is synonymous with code so a
lot of times ciphering code just means
the same
thing notice that this has an i and this
has a y
both are valid spellings i put both of
them in here just so that you're
comfortable with it
if you're in canada or the uk uh
we like to use the y if you're in the
states or other places they like
to use the i so both are okay when you
use a cipher
the output is a cipher text and so
basically it takes plain text and just
looks like scrambled text
and so here's an example and this is way
back in the day it kind of makes the
illustration pretty clear but this was a
a code book and it would store different
cryptographic codes so if we were to
zoom in here
if you're given the code zero two
um or zero four uh it could mean uh this
or i suppose like the word canoe could
also mean has the authority so
there's a bit of an encoding there uh or
sorry like a cipher there to understand
that translation so hopefully that makes
it clear
[Music]
so to complete the puzzle for encryption
you have a cipher and a key so a
cryptographic key is a variable used in
conjunction with an encryption algorithm
in order to encrypt or decrypt data and
so we have two uh types of keys we have
symmetric keys
and this is when you use the same key
for encoding decoding so
here is my key right i have my plain
text
i use that key it turns it into cipher
text notice the text is not human
readable
and then i use the same key to turn it
back into plain text and the most common
uh symmetric encryption is aes and
you'll definitely see that when working
with azure aws or any cloud service
provider
then you have symmetric encryption or
say asymmetric encryption this is when
you use two keys
one key to encode and one key to decode
and so
very similar process but the keys are
separated uh the most popular case here
is rsa
okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at the concepts of hashing
and salting so hashing is a function
that accepts an arbitrary size of values
and maps it to a fixed size data
structure and hashing
can reduce the size of the stored value
now
that is a benefit of hashing but that's
not necessarily why we're using hashing
so
hashing is a one-way process meaning
once you turn that text into a hash
it's basically unreadable at that point
and it's deterministic meaning that
um it's a it it's a process where
the input will always produce the same
output so if you always give it john
smith it's always going to produce
o2 all right now the hash can be
whatever it doesn't necessarily mean
john smith will be o2 it's just based on
what the hashing function
uh uh operates like how it works okay so
the use case for hashing
is for hashing passwords if you have a
database you do not want them to reside
in plain text
because if a malicious actor gets in
they can just see all the passwords so
by hashing it
it obscures what the password is now the
way you would authenticate against the
password because
if a user inputs a password you have to
match against it you just have to
hash the the inputted password and then
match it against um the hash password
right the hashed values
and so popular hashing functions are md5
shot 36356
and b [ __ ] b crypt is pretty popular
that's what everyone uses because it's
very long
and good uh if an attacker knows what
what function you are using
so if it knows uh the hashing function
then
that's an issue because you know they
might not be able to see the password
but they can enumerate against
uh enumerate means like iterate through
a bunch of passwords they have to
determine what the password is
so a preventative measure so they can't
enumerate uh using a dictionary a
password dictionary
is to salt the password so a salt is a
random string not known to the attacker
that the hash function accepts to
mitigate the deterministic nature of
hashing functions
okay so that is hashing insulting
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at digital signatures
and signings so what is a digital
signature it's a mathematical scheme
for verifying the authenticity of
digital messages or documents
and a digital signature gives us temper
uh tamper evidence
so imagine you had uh objects on your
desk
if you took something like baby powder
which is a fine grain dust and spread it
over your desk
if someone were to move your items you
would see uh
clearly see that they have been moved
because there'd be an outline between
the powder and the
area that had no powder underneath the
objects and that's an example a real
world example of tamper evidence
so it's going to answer did someone mess
or modify
the data is this data not from the
expected sender that's what these tamper
evidence are telling us
so there are three algorithms to digital
signatures and so there is a visual
example that i
got from wikipedia i couldn't be
bothered to make an image today but
the idea is you have key generation so
generates a public and private key so
there are our two keys
public and private and so we have the
signing so this is the process of
generating a digital signature
with a private key and the inputted
message so we have our private key
and we have our inputted message and
then you can see that it's attached
to our message here you have signing
verification
so verify the authenticity of a message
with a public key
so when it's received by the other
person we use the public key to
determine that it is from the person we
think that it's from and it hasn't been
tampered with
so a very famous example of this would
be ssh
so this is used for logging into remote
virtual machines and we use a public and
private key to authorize remote access
to that machine uh and what you do is
you probably use the ssh keygen command
this is a very well known command
and i have it memorized because i've
used it so many times and so will you
and notice it has a hyphen t so it says
that we want to take rsa as the input
that is the type of
algorithm that we are using um to
generate out
uh that okay and remember earlier on
when we were talking about
asymmetric keys where there was two keys
and we mentioned rsa
that's the same key here okay one other
thing i want to mention is code signing
just because when you hear signing you
might see code signing what the
difference is
this is just when you use a digital
signature to ensure computer code has
not been tampered with
all right so if you have a repository uh
you know people might try to
inject bad code into your repo and this
is one way to prevent it okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are comparing in
transit versus at rest encryption so
encryption and transit is data that is
secure
when moving between locations and our
algorithms that we'll see here is
tls and ssl for encryption at rest this
is data that's secure when residing on
storage or within a database
and so algorithms here could be used
would be aes
or ras all right we've covered aes and
res but let's talk about
tls and ssl so tls which stands for
transport layer security
is an encryption protocol for data
integrity between two or more
communicating computer
applications tls is deprecated in favor
of
ssl that means that we don't use it
anymore but every time
you know we mention encryption transit
or ssl everyone always mentions tls
where ssl originates from so even though
we don't use it you just see everyone
always mentioning it
so ssl stands for secure socket layers
and it's an encryption protocol for data
integrity between two or more
communicating computer applications
how it's different from tls i can't
remember myself
but i just want you to know that ssl is
the one that is used today
so when you connect to a website you see
https that is using ssl
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at multi-factor
authentication
also known as mfa and that's how i'll
refer to it through the entire course
and it's a security control where after
you fill in your email and password
you have to use a second device such as
a phone
to confirm that it's you that is logging
in so mfa protects against people who
have
stolen your password mfa is an option in
most cloud providers and even
social media websites such as facebook
so here it is example you see my email
my password
and uh that is called one factor so i've
confirmed my identity
like uh in this one case and then you
have the second factor
also known as multi-factor that's
usually what we call it and then that's
going to let us get into the system
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at security
information event management
s-i-e-m so to understand this we're just
going to define a couple things so
what is log management well this focuses
on simple collection
and storage of log messages and audit
trails
then you have event logs so system and
applications generate events
which are kept in event logs list of
activities that occurred
with records of new events being
appended to the end of the logs as they
occur
so when we say what is a security
information management sim this is the
long-term storage as well as
analysis and reporting of log data then
you have an sem
so this is for security event management
so real-time monitoring
correlation events and notifications of
consoles
notice here logs logs
events events okay so there's a
correlation between these two
definitions for you
so what is security information event
management well it's simply the
combination of a sim and a sem
to provide real-time analysis of
security alerts generated by the
network hardware and applications so
here we have our
s-i-e-m and we would have features like
log collection
log analysis uh event correlation log
forensic i.t compliance
application log monitoring object access
auditing
real time alerting user activity
monitoring dashboards reporting
file integrity monitoring system and
device monitoring
or log monitoring and log retention so
you can see that this tool does a lot
and it's very important in your security
tool belt
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at security
orchestration and automated response
also known as soar
and this collects data about security
threats and responds to security events
without human assistance so
the source system will trigger
action-driven automated workflows these
are called
playbooks and processes uh the process
to run security tasks that mitigate the
issue
so for security orchestration there's
two components here security
orchestration
and automated response so for security
orchestration it connects various
internal or external security tools
via built-in or custom integration so
possible connectors and this is not an
exhaustive list
but vulnerability scanners endpoint
protection and user behavior analytics
firewalls intrusion detection
protection systems security information
and event management so
ciem threat intelligence feeds so for
the security automation side
it analyzes the injected data to create
playbooks
so these are repeatable automated
processes to replace manual processes
it'll be replacing things like
vulnerability scanning
log analysis ticket checking auditing
and a sort can use ai and ml to provide
recommendations and further automate
responses
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at extended detection
response of xdr
and so this is a cross-layer detection
and response security system
and xdr uses a holistic approach detect
and respond to threats that would
normally evade detection
in a single vector solution by
collaborating
multiple data sources into a
multi-vector solution so
here is our xcr and what we need is a
data lake to store these various data so
we get network data fire
email endpoints cloud workloads and the
xtr is going to allow us to do things
like automated detection
sweeping hunting root clause analysis
and we can use that with our siem or
soar so this can be used to uh
to augment uh these other solutions here
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at endpoint detection
in response to edr
and this combines real-time continuous
monitoring and collection of endpoint
data
with rules based on automated response
and analysis capabilities
i'm sure i explained somewhere else in
the course but an endpoint is an entry
uh is an entry or gate on your security
perimeter it's a way to enter the
network
okay and so ed edps are designed to
detect
apt so what is an apt it stands for
advanced persistent threat
and the idea here is that these threats
will breach a security perimeter so
through an endpoint
and take up residence within a network
to steal as much data as it can over a
long period of time
apts are threat actors so they're not
software they're actually people behind
them
that engineer specific malware
engineered for a particular
target apts are slow acting and stealthy
and common targets for apts are tier one
manufacturers defense contractors
government agencies
so how an ed edr is going to help you
is this going to do detection so
behavioral analysis advanced detection
techniques
ioc scans for response it has automated
response on
discovery quick response during the
investigation multiple response options
and for investigation it has it has root
cause attack visualizations
uh enriched attack data very similar it
seems very similar to an
xdr but the edrs are focused all around
endpoints and xdrs are a lot more
broader so um you know edrs could just
do better job with endpoints okay but
you can use both
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at cloud access
security brokers
also known as casb and this system sits
between the cloud user
and the cloud application and monitors
all activity enforces security policies
so on the left-hand side
you'd have your remote workforce maybe
they're working from home
maybe they're on the job like at a a
remote location
then you have your corporate office so
this is where everyone would be in a
very controlled environment
but all that traffic is going to pass
through the csb and the idea here is
you'll get control of monitoring
compliance management data security and
threat protection for your cloud
services whether it's
software as a service platform as a
service or infrastructure as a service
so some of the features to help you
think about what csb can do for you
uh is it has monitoring user activity
warning administrators about potential
hazardous actions enforcing security
policy compliance
automatically preventing malware
restricts unauthorized access
identify account takeovers uncovers
shadow
cloud i.t or just shadow i.t is an easy
way to say it
cloud data loss prevention internal
external data access controls
records an audit trail of risky behavior
cloud phishing malware threats and
continuous monitoring of new cloud
threats now i would say that if i had to
highlight any of them out of here and i
really should have put this in red here
is i would say uncover
shadow i t and if that doesn't make
sense don't worry we explain it later
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are exploring the concept of
security posture
and in order to do that we're just going
to have to set up some additional terms
here this one is very
term loaded so get ready for this the
first one here is malicious actors also
known as threat
actors or attackers i like to call them
malicious actors
it is a person machine or entity of an
event or
incident that impacts or has the
potential to impact the safety or
security of another entity
this is the bad person okay inventory so
up-to-date lists of uh assets software
and hardware for your organization
that can be accompanied with additional
metadata there's a different kinds of
assets in our inventory so we have
perimeter assets
assets exposed to the internet so public
facing core assets assets within your
private
network private facing when we say
attack vector this is the method of a
malicious attack
uses that they use to breach or
infiltrate a network
they could target infrastructure or a
human for weakness
and a lot of the cases we're seeing more
human engineered attack vectors
than going directly for infrastructure
the attack surface is the sum
of the attack factors the larger the
inventory
generally increases the amount of attack
vectors the larger the attack surface
the more difficult it is to mitigate
attacks then you have security controls
you'll hear this word security controls
over and over again
in this course controls are safeguards
or counter measures to avoid detect
counteract or minimize security risks
and then we can answer what a security
posture is so a formula
to determine the overall effectiveness
of a company's security overall defense
we're talking about azure they call it a
security score and it's basically a
number
and then you can go drill down and look
at the security controls and the
security controls can map out to your
inventory so this is how you kind of see
they're all tied together
if we wanted to kind of describe how you
would evaluate or assess the security
posture
uh here i got a little quick list here
so we collect information by asking
common questions so
it could be what data do we collect how
and where are we storing this data
how do we protect it uh uh we protect
and document the data how long do we
keep the data
who has access to the internally
external data is the place
we are storing the data properly secured
wipe that out there that's a bit of a
mess
um security ratings aka security scores
so data driven
objective and dynamic measurements of an
organization security posture
created by a trusted independent
security rating
platform so that is security posture and
we'll definitely see it
mentioned about like three times in this
course okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at cloud security
posture management also known as cspm
and this identifies and remediates risks
through security assessments and
automated compliance and monitoring
to give a kind of a visual for what this
thing does so you have the cspm in the
middle
around it you got automation lifecycle
governance
and brokerage and extending that a
little bit further you got provisioning
orchestration
cost management resource optimization
cloud migration backup disaster recovery
identity security compliance
uh packaging and delivery monitoring
analytics inventory and classification
and service requests so to reiterate you
know a cspm
assesses your system it automatically
alerts security staff in your it
departments when a vulnerability is
found
and so some security tools we can expect
to see in here is zero trust based
access controls
real-time risk scoring threat and
vulnerability management that is a very
uh very useful cases of the tvms
discover
uh sharing risks technical policy threat
modeling system and architecture
teams that would use a ces pm would be
your threat intelligence team your
information technology
your compliance and risk management
teams your business leaders your
smes uh your security architecture
operations and your audit team okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at just in time and just
enough privileges
these two terms come up a lot in
microsoft and azure
documentation but they don't fully
explain them to you so i'm taking the
time up front here
so that you know it when you see the
initialism so
just in time also known as jit is giving
access to resources only during the time
when needed reducing the surface attack
uh based on the range of time access so
someone only needs something for two
minutes
uh give it to them and take it away
right so and and give them access to
things near the time that they need it
so
if they're not gonna use it from an hour
from now don't give them give it to them
so there's an hour window give it to
them exactly when they're using it and
when they're and take it away when they
exactly aren't using it
then you have just enough privilege so
known as jep so giving access to only
the specific actions reducing the
surface
attack by providing the least privileged
principles this is
pretty much uh the principle of least
privilege
which is another initialism i'm sure
we'll see in the course but for some
reason they call it this here
but these are the two things you'll see
throughout microsoft and azure
documentation
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at ingress egress so
very outdated but very clear graphic of
how these two things work so ingress is
traffic
that's entering a network boundary and
anger or egress
is traffic exiting a network boundary
and you're if you're wondering where
these terms came from they're latin
so ingressus and i don't i don't speak
latin so i'm not pronouncing it properly
and there's some variations on how to
pronounce latin so who knows but ingress
would mean to
advance walk walking or an entry whereas
egress is the opposite is
it's to leave okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at the concept of
shadow i.t which is a business agility
process where departments can purchase
and provision their own i.t resources
without the approval of the
organization's centralized i.t
department so the advantage of shadow
i.t systems allows organization to
innovate and quickly prototype future
solutions but the disadvantage of shadow
i.t systems increase risk
with organizational requirements for
security controls
compatibility with compliance programs
loss of data or unexpected data exposure
documentation reliability so uh you know
you get great agility but then you need
additional security services which we
talked about earlier to
make sure that there's no abuse of the
shadow i.t systems
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at automation
investigation and remediation so
investigation is when you're gathering
evidence from a digital system to
uncover malicious intent or reduction in
a security posture
remediation is the action of remedying
a as something to prevent or revert a
disaster the act of changing a resource
back to the desired state or state that
does not cause a problem
so in the context of cloud security a
cloud resource is being remediated to
stay compliant
with our expected security controls so
prevention would be something like
turning the virtual machine off if the
port 22 was exposed
reverting would be turning back on
encryption if a
disk encryption is disabled so to revert
so to put it back in the previous state
so for the systems here we have
automated investigation this is a
service
that uses an inspection algorithm that
triggers an alert which in turn creates
an incident
and then we have automated remediation a
service which watches for types of
incidents
uh incidents and matches it with a
remediation action so it could be
something like shutting off a server and
so
air so it's just the combination of
these two systems so
automated investigation and automated
remediation okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at threat analysis and
this is the practice of mitigating
possible threats via threat modeling
and threat modeling is a structured
process for identifying attackers and
cataloging past possible threats
and so there's a lot of different
methodologies for this
and some to point out would be stride
which is developed by microsoft
uh pasta or pasta yeah i think that's
how you'd say it process of attack
simulation
and threat analysis it's a seven uh
seven-step risk-centric methodology you
have trike which is an open source
threat modeling process mal which stands
for mel
meta attack language a domain specific
language used for
uh threat modeling and attack
simulations uh and so
you know that's that but we'll look at
more detail here at stride okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at the stride
methodology and so stride is for threat
modeling as we just mentioned a moment
ago
and it can categorize different threats
into the following so
the first is spoofing so illegally
accessing and then
using another user's authentication
information tampering so malicious
modification of data
repudiation so illegal operation in
a system that lacks ability to trace the
prohibited operation
information disclosure so exposure of
information to individuals who are not
exposed
to have access to it denial of service
deny
service to valid users and elevation of
privileges unprivileged
uh users gain uh privileged access so
if you notice that spells stride
all right so if we wanted to use stride
we have the microsoft security
development life cycle
and it provides a tool to assist with
this process and i believe they call it
the microsoft threat modeling tool
and it makes threat modeling easier for
all developers through a standard
notation for
visualizing system components data flows
and security boundaries
[Music]
all right so i wanted to actually show
off the microsoft threat modeling tool
so you get an idea what it can do
so i typed in microsoft threat modeling
tool and on the left hand side here
there's a bunch of releases i actually
didn't choose the latest one which i
probably should have but if you scroll
on down you'll see this thing that says
microsoft threat modeling tool
and i've opened it up and it looks like
this and so they have an example model
if we open it up we can see what we have
here so basically it's a stenciling tool
of generic things
and so i mean you don't have to use this
you could use something like
lucidcharts or something else to threat
modeling but it's nice that this is a
free program
and it literally was like four megabytes
to install if we wanted to see kind of
an example that is more particular to
azure
we have threat model templates here and
so
you can see that there's stencils for
these particular resources
so i guess the idea is that you know we
might not have those stencils those
azure stencils
and so this one i guess adds it to the
service so if we expand here
we can see some threat modeling for um
azure
and so you know you have your your
boundaries for your corporate net
and then if we scroll on over we have
our azure trust boundary and then our
resource group trust boundary and you
can see kind of where information flows
between different services so like azure
events
data factory things like that so you
know hopefully that gives you a visual
idea what um
threat modeling is uh but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at intrusion detection
and protection
and so we have two systems here rolled
into one so the first is ids intrusion
detection system
it monitors a network or system for
malicious activity or policy violations
and the idea is that once it detects
something it's going to create an
incident and so that you can go through
an itemized list to
take action then you have an ips so
intrusion protection system
this restricts or reacts to the detected
malicious activity
taking action doing something about it
if you roll these two
into one you get an ids ips and this is
how they are often
offered in the market you're really
going to see these things separated out
as separate offerings okay
if you're figuring out okay well how
does an ids actually detect
incidences it has three ways of doing it
the first is signature-based detection
this is a simple technique where it uses
a signature
and a signature is a set of rules that
an ids and an ips
uses detect typical intrusion activity
it compares signatures against
observed events to identify possible
incidents uh then you have
anomaly-based detection this is a more
advanced technique
and so it compares definitions of what
is considered normal activity with
observed events in order to identify
significant deviations then you have
stateful protocol analysis this is a
profile technique
it compares to predetermined profiles or
generally accepted
definitions of benign protocol activity
for each protocol state
against observed events in order to
identify deviations
no matter which one you're using
whatever your provider is
you want to turn this stuff on
immediately because
an ips ids is only useful if you have a
baseline
a a look at what normal activity looks
like within your network
so you cannot turn this stuff on late in
the game you got to turn it on
on day one okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at the mitre attack
framework so first of all what is mitre
it is a not-for-profit organization
supporting various us government
agencies in the aviation defense
healthcare homeland security
and cyber security fields and then we
have the
mitre attack framework and this is a
globally accessible knowledge base of
adversary tactics and techniques
based on real-world observations look
down below you can see there's a lot of
stuff in here
if you're thinking about this knowledge
base you might say well what is the
purpose of it but it's used as a
foundation for the development of
specific threat
models and methodologies in the private
sector government and cyber security
product and service community
it has a website it's easy to view you
just go to attack.mitre.org
and i think it's really great because if
you look around it gives you kind of an
idea of things that you have to be
thinking about okay
[Music]
okay so i wanted to get you some
exposure to the attack.miter.org just
because i know you saw a screenshot but
it always helps to take a quicker look
here
if we scroll on down below we have
categories across the top that are
interested so maybe you're interested in
privileged escalation
but you know we can drill down here and
say okay well what in particular are we
interested in
so let's say we want to look at
exploitation of privileged
escalation they have a full description
on here and procedure examples
of things that you can do so there is a
lot of stuff in here
okay so uh you know if you're wondering
uh what it is that you need to do oh it
just keeps on going you really drill
down here and
and read a lot of stuff but this really
really does help you get a
a full idea of the type of attacks that
can happen on your system so
definitely if you have more time check
it out
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're going to look at the
six microsoft privacy principles so the
first being control
which is we will put you in control of
your privacy with ease of use tools and
clear choices
second being transparency will be
transparent about the data collection
and
uh and we use so you can make informed
decisions
number three we will protect the data
you entrust uh to us
through strong security encryption
number four
strong legal protection so we will
respect your local privacy laws and
fight for legal protection for your
privacy as a fundamental human right
number five no content based targeting
so we will not use your email chat files
or personal
uh content to target ads at you have a
hard time believing that fifth one but
hey they say they don't do it
number six benefits to you so we will uh
when we do collect data we will use it
to benefit
you and make sure your experiences uh
to make your experiences better so it's
kind of funny because like it seems like
number six could contradict number five
but
you know if they saw it as a benefit to
you but yeah that's the microsoft
privacy principle
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're looking at microsoft privacy
not to be confused with microsoft
privacy principles
and the reason why there's uh privacy
again here it's just because microsoft
is a big organization
and sometimes they have marketing
efforts that overlap or conflict
and it gets kind of confusing which is
which
and that's just microsoft being
microsoft for you but we're going to go
through it anyway because
regardless of which one is more
important i think it's just good to get
good coverage here and it's explained in
a slightly different way so
helps you understand how these providers
think uh
you know about your data so starting at
the top here we have control your data
so you
your data belongs to you you can access
modify or delete it at any time
you're in control of your data it's
reinforced by microsoft compliance so
gdpr iso 2718
they have independent audit reports data
processing
only with consent neither shared or
mined for market research and
advertising
subcon subcontractors data restrictions
so aka sub processors
can perform only the function that
microsoft has hired them to provide
and they're bound by the same
contractual privacy commitments that
microsoft makes to you
for controlled data location you choose
where your data is located so
choice of data center data residency
residency meaning like the boundaries
of a country or a geographic boundary
we're talking about securing your data
so data at rest they use a
aes 256 encryption dating transit ssl
and tls
encryption keys you have azure key vault
for defending your data responding to
data
requests they will not disclose data to
a government or a law enforcement
agency unless required by law law
enforcement requests
so direct the requesting party to seek
the data directly from the customer so
they're not doing it uh on your behalf
okay uh
our they have contact contractual
commitments
so using the courts to challenge
governments demands that are
inconsistent with the rule of law so
they're always fighting on your side
uh they have gdr compliance so disclose
their data in response to a government
request
in violation of uh eu's gdpr
disclose their data in response so gdpr
compliance
that could have been worded better i'm
taking it from their content by the way
but gdpr is
is like if you're a european citizen you
can say hey i don't want you to hold on
to my data
so show me what you have uh about me and
also
can you uh delete it okay that's what
that is there
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at primary security
perimeter
this is a super important concept and
has a lot to do with identity and azure
id so
pay close attention here so what is
security perimeter so barriers are built
fortifications to either keep intruders
out or to keep
captives contained within the area the
boundary surrounds so when we're talking
about a data center
we're talking about the physical fence
as the security perimeter that's just
one
mechanism of security perimeter for
cloud network we're talking about
protocol software hardware as the
security perimeter
so what is an entry point this is the
point of entry to cross a security
perimeter
and then we have access controls and
these are the security mechanisms at the
point of access that allow
or denies access when we're talking
about permission
to access a resource this is called
authorization
and so what is a primary security
perimeter so traditional security
focused on
firewalls vpn since there were fewer
employees or workstations outside the
office
but now that we have bring your own
devices remote workstations
it is much more common now to access
controls via a zero trust model
i really should have highlighted that in
yellow or red like that support
very important and uh zero trust models
are being adopted
so we see mfa and we see a shift towards
user identity management becoming the
primary security
primary perimeter for security so the
primary security perimeter
is user identity management and so when
we're talking about azure it's going to
be azure active directory
because this is the most common tool
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're taking a look here at ipd's so
identity providers is a system entity
that creates maintains and manages
identity for
information four principles and also
provides authentication services to
applications within a federation or
distributed network
a trusted provider or of your user
identity that lets you use
authentication to access other services
is another way to put it
so an ipd could be something like
facebook amazon google twitter github
linkedin
if you've ever used some service that
said log in with your facebook account
or google account
that's what an ipd is so federated
identity is a method of linking a user's
identity across
multiple separate identity management
systems so a federation
is just a collection of identities uh we
have a few different technologies
that are involved with ipds so the first
is open id this is an open standard and
decentralized authentication protocol
so this allows you to log in with
different social media platforms
such as google or facebook open id is
about providing who you
are auth 2.0 or oauth 2.0 is an industry
standard protocol for authorization of
oauth doesn't share your password data
but instead uses authorization tokens to
prove an identity between the consumer
and service provider and so oauth is
about
granting access to functionality so you
can use open id and oauth 2.0 together
the last is saml security assertion mark
markup language it's an open standard
for exchanging authentication
authorization between identity providers
and service provider
uh it's a use case for saml which is
single sign-on with web browser
whenever using azure id and you want to
connect to web app you're gonna be
looking at using saml okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and this is our introduction into aziv
active directory also known as azure ad
and it's microsoft's
cloud-based identity and access
management service which helps your
employees sign in and access resources
it's going to help us both externally
and with internal resources so on the
external side we're looking at microsoft
365
the azure portal sas applications and
for internal resources
so those are apps that reside within
your internal network
uh access to workstations uh that may
reside on premise
uh and one of the best features of azure
ad is single sign-on that's what a lot
of companies want it for
uh in terms of uh the types of azure
active directory there are
it's broken down to four editions with
each uh
subsequent tier having all the features
of the previous tier and so we have the
free tier where you get multi-factor
authentication
single sign-on basic security usage
reports user management
you have office 365 apps so that will
give you company branding
sla to sync between on-premise and cloud
and the last two which
i want you to notice and take note of
because we do mention a lot of the
features in this course for these two
tiers
it's premium one and premium two als
commonly abbreviated to p1 and p2 so you
have hybrid architecture advanced group
access
conditional access and for premium two
you have identity protection identity
governance so again as we move up the
tier
each of the previous tier has all the
features of the prior one so premium one
has
or sir premium two has all the features
of premium one
in terms of uh the use case for azure id
it's for uh
authorizing and authenticating to
multiple sources so whether it's on
premise your active directory to your
web app
uh to allow for um identity like using
identity providers
or to connect to microsoft 365 or
microsoft azure
azure id takes care of all this stuff
and so when we're looking at hybrid
connections we're talking about azure ad
connect
when we're looking at integrating our
applications that is through
app registrations where we have uh the
b2c service and we'll talk about that
in greater detail then you have external
identities so that's going to be for
your ipds
uh and then you can also easily
integrate with cloud applications
there's no particular service
like subservice for that it's just azure
id naturally does that okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're comparing
active directory versus azure active
directory because they're not the same
thing
so active directory has been around for
quite a long time
it's been around since windows 2000 and
it was first introduced as
active directory domain services to give
organizations the ability to manage
multiple
on-premise infrastructure components and
systems using a single identity
per user and so azure ad takes this
approach to the next level by providing
organizations
with an identity as a service so an idas
solution for their apps across cloud and
on-premise so both
are still used today so there's active
directory which is used for on-premise
and there's azure ad which is the cloud
version
and so we see a lot of companies might
want to migrate over to azure id
or they might have a particular legacy
licensing that makes it more cost
effective or there might be certain
security compliances where
that's why they're not using azure id so
both of these are still valid products
just different use cases okay
let's take a closer look here at azure
ad for app registration so app
registrations allow developers to
integrate web applications to use azure
id to authenticate users
and request access to user resources
such as email
calendar and documents and this allows
you to implement single sign-on into
your web applications
the way you access it is you just go to
your azure id and there's a section
under there called app registrations
we're definitely going to cover a little
bit more about
app registrations when we talk about
azure 80 uh
b2c because that is the actual way of uh
doing authentication and we'll cover
more about app registration there
but just a quick introduction here okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at azure id
external identities and the idea here is
that it allows people outside your
organization to access your apps and
resources while letting them sign in
using whatever identity they prefer so
whether it's your partners distributors
suppliers vendors or other guest users
you can bring your own identities so it
supports logins like google and facebook
there's
so many more and i'll show you in a
moment but the idea here is you can
share your apps with external users
develop apps intended for azure ad
tenants develop white label apps for
consumers and customers
and there's two identity external
identities so there's b2b and b2c so b2b
is when you're working with another
organization and they probably have
their own azure ad
or their own identity service that they
want to
connect to your app or services and b2c
is when you're dealing with customers
they're not part of an identity
service they're just individuals okay
and so when we're talking about uh
ipd support so identity providers it's a
big old list here so you've got
adfs amazon apple azure ad single tenant
multi-tenant
to b2c ebay facebook generic identity
providers github id dot me
google linkedin microsoft account qq
salesforce salesforce sample protocol
twitter
wechat and weboo and this is pretty darn
um
thorough because when you look at amazon
cognito which is aws is offering
does not have linkedin does not have
twitter does not have github
i mean one of these might be able to be
possible but it's very hard to
implement on theirs and so this is where
i feel that azure adb to c has a
competitive advantage
maybe not as great as uh okta uh which
is
a third party but i think that azure 80
b2c beats them on price for sure
and meets most use cases if we're going
to just do a quick comparison between
the b2b and b2c offering just to really
solidify the difference
we break it down into scenario intended
uh ipd support etc etc
so let's just go through here and see
what the difference is so look at the
scenario
collaboration using microsoft
applications this one is an im for
modern sas or custom developed
applications for intended
use cases uh collaborating with business
partners for from external organizations
and this is customers of your product
for identity support you have work
accounts school accounts
any email address saml wsfed
based identity providers gmail facebook
and
for a b2c you have local applications
social identities
users with corporate and gov identities
et cetera b2c i believe it's more
expansive
between the two external user management
managed in the same directory as
employees and then for b2c managed
separately from the organization
employees and partner directories
for sso azure india connected app is
supported and for
sso on b2c it's customer owned apps with
azure adb
2c tenants is supported for policy and
compliance managed by the host inviting
organization
and for b2c it's managed by the
organizations via conditional access
identity protection for branding the
host inviting organization brand is used
and for b2c it's fully customized
branding per application or organization
for billing models they're both based on
monthly active users so
maus and there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at service
principles for azure id and this
is a security identity used by
applications or services to access
specific
azure resources so a service principle
is created when a
user from the tenant has consented to
the applications or api use
and so what you do is you go over to app
registrations
to be able to set up a service principle
so
this defines who can access the
application and what resources the
application can access so down below
you can see we have a few different
options here so whether it's
the organizational directory from the
current company or a different one or
whether you're allowed to use a personal
account so
a service principle is created in each
tenant where the application is used and
references the global unique
application object so after you've
registered your application you're going
to have an object id and application id
that's what i was talking about earlier
when i said about application
registration we come back to it well
this is the part where
we're seeing how that works so the
application id represents the global
applications
across all tenants and the object id is
a unique
value for an application object so there
you go
[Music]
so manage identities within azure id
are used to manage the credentials for
authenticating a cloud application with
an azure service so
using a managed identity you can
authenticate to any service
that supports azure id authentication
without having
credentials in your code that is why we
want managed identity to remember that
there are two types of managed
identities system assigns so an identity
in an azure id tied to a life cycle
for a service instance when the resource
is deleted
so is the system assigned to the manage
identity for user assigned it's an
identity assigned to one or more
instance of services the identity is
managed separately from the resource
when the resources deleted the identity
remains i want to drill this in so let's
do a quick table here between systems
and user assigns so for creation
created as part of the azure resource
for user assign created as a standalone
azure resource for life cycle
shared lifecycle with the azure resource
for user assigned the independent it has
an independent life cycle for deletion
when you delete the resource so does the
identity go with it
for user design it must be explicitly
deleted for sharing across azure
resources
cannot be shared associated with a
single azure resource for users
assigned can be shared can be associated
with
more than one azure resource okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at device
management for azure id so let's just
define what device identity management
is
it is the management of physical devices
such as phones tablets laptops desktops
computers
that are granted access to company
resources such as printers
and cloud resources via device-based
conditional access so
here's what it would look like if you
opened up device manager and you had
connected some devices
notice on the left hand side we got
ourselves um a oops i use the highlight
tool i want the pen tool
but we have some desktops and laptops we
could have phones in here as well
and there are different types of join
types which we'll talk about here in a
moment
and you can apply mdm and we'll talk
about mdm and mam in the
upcoming slides but for companies with a
distributed workforce that allows remote
employees
and who are allowed to use their own
personal equipment this is what we call
bring your own device so you should know
byod
a company needs a way to protect their
organization's assets such as
access to cloud resources across the
devices where they have less control
over the physical securities of the work
environment so device management
this stuff really ties back to the zero
truss model that we talked about all the
way at the start of this course
um and this really illustrates how the
identity is really your
your uh the first security perimeter
okay
for uh getting devices into device
management there are three different
ways we have azure id registered so
this is where you have personally owned
or mobile devices you're signed in with
a personal microsoft or local account
and you'd be using things like windows
10 ios android mac os
for azure 80 joined it's owned by an
organization signed in with
an azure id account belonging to the
organization they exist only in the
cloud
and you look at windows 10 windows
server 2019 for hybrid azure ad joined
it's owned by an organization uh
you are signed in with azure director
active directory
not azure sorry active directory domain
services accounts belonging to the
organization
and they exist in the cloud or
on-premise you're looking at windows 7
8.110 windows server 2008 or newer
uh they're not going to ask you about
all these details in the exam but you
should know broadly these three
categories and that
uh you know the hybrids for hybrid azure
id join is for
um uh is cloud only for organizations
and this one top one here is for
personal
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at mdm and
mam so
mobile device management allows you to
control the entire device
wipe data from it and also reset it to
factory settings where mobile
application management
allows you to publish push configure
secure monitor and update mobile apps
for your users
and both of these features are found
under your azure ad so there you would
add an application such as microsoft
intune and that's what you'd be using
to get mdm and mam features uh microsoft
intune
uh has to be to get access to it you
have to upgrade to azure ad premium two
and microsoft intune is now part of
microsoft endpoint manager
used to be a standalone service but now
it's part of this and microsoft endpoint
manager and intune are part of the
microsoft enterprise mobility security
uh ems it's just like a suite of
services that work together
so i know it's a bit confusing but in
tune is is part of endpoint manager
which is part of ems okay
[Music]
so windows hello gives windows 10 users
an alternative way to log into their
devices and application using
fingerprint iriscan
facial recognition so these are
biometrics an authentication type with
windows hello would include microsoft
account
active directory account azure ad
identity provider services or something
like 502 which is a security key so i
think ub key
windows hello pin is backed by a trusted
platform module tpm
chip it has multiple physical security
mechanisms to make it tamper resistant
the windows hello pin is more secure
than a standard pin because it is tied
to a specific device
so the pin is for that device and only
for that device okay
there's two offerings here we have
windows hello windows hello for business
there's a lot more details here but i'm
just going to give you the
the the main difference so windows hello
is for individual consumers
and windows hello for business is for
business uh windows hello uses a pin
backed by hashing where windows hello
uses a pin backed by an asymmetric
public and private
key or certificate-based authentication
if you're a member or primer you know
that
a public and private key is just a lot
more secure with windows hello for
business you can also use group policies
so gpo
and mdm okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're taking a look here at azure 80
connect which is a hybrid service to
connect your on-premise active directory
to your azure account azure 80 connect
allows for seamless single sign-on from
your on-premise workstation to microsoft
azure
and it allows you to connect in the in
the following ways so we have
password hash synchronization which is a
sign in method that synchronizes the
hash of users on premise 80 password
azure id
password through authentication this is
a sign in method that allows users to
use the same password on premise
and in the cloud federation integration
this is a hybrid environment using
on-premise adfs infrastructure for
certificate renewal
these three are the authentication types
okay so you want to remember those three
some additional features we should cover
the synchronization so responsible for
creating users groups
other objects ensures on-prem and cloud
data matches
and health monitoring robust monitoring
and provides a central location in the
azure portal to view activity
this last one is called azure 80 connect
health okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at self-service
password reset
also known as sspr this allows users to
change or reset their password without
the help of an administrator
free up your help desk support requests
add additional layer security and keep
users more productive
so self-service password scenarios
include password change so when a user
knows their password but wants to change
it to something new
password reset when a user can't sign in
such as when they forget the password
and want to reset
account unlock when a user can't sign in
because their account is
locked out so authentication methods for
ssrp would be like mobile app
notifications mobile app codes
email mobile phones office phones and
security questions okay
[Music]
let's take a look at a feature called
azure ad password protection and to
understand
this we need to know the concept of
password spraying and this is a type of
brute force dictionary attack
uh and uh the idea here is that identity
systems
mitigate traditional brute force attacks
by having lockout and after
a lockout would be after a certain
amount of temps
uh the user is locked out and has to
wait a short period of time before they
can try their password again you've seen
this like five attempts
and then you're locked out for like 30
minutes so password spraying circumvents
lockout by spraying the same password
across multiple accounts before trying
another password
while the lockout time cools down or
resets
and so azure id password protection is a
feature of azure id to protect your
passwords from identity tags such as
password spray attacks okay the uh the
mechanisms here is we have global
uh global band password list so this is
a password list with known weak
passwords
that is automatically updated and
enforced by microsoft you don't have to
do anything you just get that
uh as you use the service then you have
a custom banned password list this is
where you're going to provide
a custom list of passwords that are more
specific
to your business security needs to get
banned passwords uh lists
you need azure ad one or two um
for hybrid security azure id password
protection can be integrated to
on-premise
active directory environments okay
[Music]
so here's just a quick list of azure
identity management best practices
it's nothing super fun here just a very
simple list but it's good for us to go
through it so we have
where we keep these things in mind so
azure identity management access control
security best practices starting with
treat identity as the primary security
perimeter
this all comes back to zero trust
policies right a centralized identity
management
manage connected tenants enable single
sign-on
turn on conditional access plan for
routine security improvements enable
password management
enable multi-factor verification for
users use role-based access controls
lower exposure of privileged accounts
control locations when resources are
located
are located and use azure ad for storage
authentication so there you go
[Music]
let's talk about the concept of
emergency access or break glass
so emergency access accounts prevent
admins from being accidentally locked
out
of their azure ad account okay so you
might have seen these kind of devices
before
think of like if there's a fire and
there's ax behind it you break the glass
so there's a key
these are just in the case of
emergencies that you can get access
so you can mitigate the impact of
accidental accidental lack of
administrative access by creating two or
more emergency access accounts
in your organization so emergency access
accounts are
highly privileged and they are not
assigned to specific individuals
they are limited to emergency or break
glass scenarios where normal
administrative accounts can't be used
recommended to maintain a maintained
goal of restricting emergency accounts
used to only the times when it's
absolutely necessary
so these accounts should be cloud only
accounts that use the onmicrosoft.com
domain
uh not federated or synchronized from an
on-premise environment
exclude at least one account from a
phone-based multi-factor authentication
exclude one account from a conditional
access policies
store these account credentials safely
and monitor sign in and audit logs all
right
[Music]
so azure active directory using mfa
allows
multiple authentication methods some of
them is sms so that's where you have a
text message and that's how you get your
pin
a voice call that has a synthesized
voice that speaks your pin we have the
microsoft authenticator app where
you can use the app and press a button
so you can do passwordless
login and you have hardware tokens so
this is where you touch your security
key and authorize it by generating it
and it will automatically generate and
enter a pin for you so we'll just kind
of dive a little bit deeper into these
methods okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a quick look here at
microsoft authenticator so this
is a web application or sorry a mobile
application you can download for either
your ios or android phone it allows for
secure sign-ins for all your online
accounts using multi-factor
authentication
password list authentication password
autofill and it's both available in the
apple
app store and google play store okay
[Music]
okay so i made my way over to the google
play store because i just want to give
you a
a closer look at this service it's not
complicated
but if you click into here you can kind
of see uh what it allows you to do so
here we have a new sign-in request for
your microsoft account so you would just
say approve or deny
so this is an example of password list
right you don't have to put in a
password to do the mfa
you can see when there are new sign-ins
on your phone
it will autofill passwords in so here
it's doing it for linkedin
you can see you can manage uh multiple
accounts and it has those
um you know those the general mfa codes
there
i can connect to multiple services so
you have your outlook
your onedrive um and office 65 in
general or microsoft 365 so
you know nothing too complicated but you
should give it an install and go
because it's pretty good
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're taking a look here at the concept
of biometrics so biometrics are body
measurements and calculations
related to the human characteristics and
biometric authentication or realistic
authentication is used in computer
science as a form of identification
and access control so we have different
kinds of characteristics there's
physiological which we'll go through
quickly here so like a fingerprint
pawn veins face recognition dna palm
print
hand geometry iris recognition retina or
odor or scent
that last one sounds uh very interesting
i've never heard of a system that can do
that but
it's on the list here behavioral
characteristics so
this would be like typing rhythm gait
keystrokes signature behavioral
profiling and voice so there you go
[Music]
so fido is a fast identity online
alliance it's an open industry
association whose mission is to develop
and promote authentication standards
that help reduce the world's over
reliance on passwords so fido alliance
has published
three sets of open specifications for
simpler stronger user authentication
the first being universal second factor
so
u2f universal authentication framework
so
uaf client to authentication protocol so
ctap
and ctap is complementary to the w3c web
authentication so web
auth n and together those are known as
fido 2.
so the reason we're talking about fido 2
is this always comes down to security
keys
so a security key is a secondary device
used as a second step in authentication
process
to gain access to a device workstation
or application a security key can
resemble a memory stick
when your finger makes contact with a
button or exposed metal on the device it
will generate an autofill a security
token
a popular brand of security keys is the
ub key
it works out of the box with gmail
facebook and hundreds more supports 502
auth and u2f and you just noticed we
talked about all those things
this particular device is waterproof and
crest resistant works with usb-a
nfc dual connectors on a single key it's
going to vary
based on the key you get they all have
different features but
this is a good baseline to understand
security keys
[Music]
let's take a look here at open
authentication also known as
oath and i want you to know this is not
to be confused with oauth very similar
in names but not the same thing so
uh oath is an open standard that
specifies how time-based one-time
passwords so totps
codes are generated so time-based
one-time passwords is a
computer algorithm that generates a
one-time password to otp
which uses the current time as a source
of uniqueness
so uh oath totp is implemented using
either software or hardware to generate
code so
for a software oath would be generated
for something from like authenticator
and hardware oath would be generated
from a security key so
this is an example actually in microsoft
authenticator so just taking out my pen
tool here
this is the code you've you've seen
these before um so it's like three nine
three eight one three
there's a little wheel it spins and then
it will reset the time
here's more of a physical device i
imagine that this is kind of the
precursor to
uh ubiki's or mobile apps the idea is
that you'd have a physical device and it
would count down it would change the
times here okay so that's pretty much it
[Music]
password list authentication is a less
frustrating authentication method than
mfa
and password list authentication methods
are more convenient because the password
is removed and replaced with something
you have
plus something you are or something you
know so something you have could be
windows 10 device
phone security key something you are
could be a biometric
a biometric such as a fingerprint
something you know could be a pin
so or a password right so solutions for
i guess not a password could just be a
pin
but solutions for a password list
authentication include windows hello for
business
the microsoft authenticator app uh 502
security keys so
just looking here we have kind of a four
corners here inconvenient high security
convenient low security
so we put passwords on here generally
they're very convenient
everyone's used to using passwords
however they don't have the highest
amount of security from these other
options sure you can make a very strong
password but these other options are
just
passwordless authentication is a lot
more powerful when you're using
ufa or two-factor authentication
multi-factor authentication
it's highly secure but the issue with
this is that
it can be kind of a pain to pull out
your phone to get that
otp that one-time password in order to
complete that second step so password
authentic passwordless authentication is
both
highly secure and convenient okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
we're taking a look here at azure ad
conditional access which provides an
extra layer of security
before allowing authenticate users to
access data or other assets
so conditional access is implemented
through conditional access policies
and conditional access policy analyzes
signals so signal could be user location
device application real-time risk we'll
talk about that in the next slide all
the types of signals there are and
the idea is you need to verify every
access attempt via access control so you
might have require mfa
block or allow so just a visual here i
got this graphic from the microsoft
documentation
the idea is you have your signal so user
location
application real-time risk devices and
here
we have our verification steps right to
get access to our apps and data
so let's take a quicker a a closer look
at signals
so signals is metadata associated with
an identity attempting to gain access
and so some examples or actually i guess
the full list of signals that are
possible conditional access
starting with users or group memberships
so policies
target specific users and groups
including admin roles giving admins
fine grain control over access then you
can
have signals that are named location or
ip location information so that's a
range of ips
used when making policy decisions so
admins can opt to block or allow traffic
from an entire country ip range as an
example
for devices users with devices of
specific platforms are marked with a
specific state can be used
for applications users attempting to
access specific
applications can trigger different
conditional access policies real-time
real-time sign-in risk detection so
signals integration with
azure ad identity protection allows
conditional access policies to identify
risk
sign and behavior and policies can then
force users to perform
password changes mfa authentication to
reduce the risk level or block
or they're blocked from access until
administrator takes manual action
then you do you have your cloud apps or
cloud actions so cloud apps or actions
can include or exclude cloud
applications or user actions that will
be subject to policy
then there's user risk so from customers
with access to identity protection
user risk can be evaluated as part of
conditional access policy
user user risk represents the
probability that a given identity or
account is compromised
user risk can be configured for high
medium or low probability
let's talk about common decisions so
these define the access control that
define what level of access based on the
signal information and so
this is when we were talking about that
verifying steps these are those common
decisions so
we have block access so most restrictive
decision then you have grant access and
so this is the least restrictive
decision
but still requires one or more of the
following options so require mfa
require device to be marked as compliant
require hybrid azure 80 join device
require approved client app require app
uh production policy
okay so there you go
[Music]
let's take a look here at azure 80 roles
and these are used to manage
azure 80 resources in a directory such
as create or edit users assign
administrative roles to others
reset user passwords manage user
licenses manage domain
so if you're in azure id you'd see roles
and administrators on the right-hand
side
and they have a bunch of pre-built roles
of course you can make your custom ones
but a few ones that you should
absolutely know is the global
administrator this gives you full access
to everything the user administrator
this gives you full access to create and
manage users
the billing administrator which makes
purchases manage descriptions to support
tickets
and you can create custom roles but
you're going to need
azure p1 or p2 okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at azure role
based access controls or rbac
so the idea here is that you have a
security principle that represents the
identities requesting access to azure
resources so that could be a user
who has an individual profile in azure
id a group of users
uh created an azure id a service
principle and this is a security
identity used by applications or
services to access specific azure
resources
or manage identity an identity in azure
id that is automatically managed by
azure so um another thing that we
that matters when we're talking about
role-based action controls is we have to
determine the scope
and so the scope is a set of resources
that access for the role assignment
applies to
so scope access controls of the
management subscription or group
level right so you can apply at this
level a description level or the
resource group level
um just so you know okay the role
definition is a collection of
permissions
a role definition lists the operations
that can be performed
such as read write and delete roles can
be high level like owner specific
like virtual machine reader and azure
has built-in roles and you can define
your own custom
roles so the ones they have built in is
owner contributor reader
user admin access and these are the four
fundamental
built-in built-in roles that azure has
so identity governance for azure id
allows you to balance your
organizational security versus
employee productivity and that ensures
the right people have the right access
to the right resources
so azure id and enterprise mobility plus
security features allow you to mitigate
asset access risks by protecting
monitoring and auditing access to
critical assets so identity governance
gives organization the ability to do the
following govern the identity life cycle
govern the access life lifecycle secure
privileges access for administration
identity governance addresses these four
questions so which
users should have access to which
resources what are those users doing
with
that access are there effective
organizational controls for managing the
access
can auditors verify the controls uh that
the the controls are working
all right
[Music]
so human capital management also known
as hcm is the practice of managing
people as resources within an
organization
so an hcm system is an application that
provides administrative and strategic
support around human resources
so for admins that's payroll benefits
employee self-service portals for
strategic we're talking about workflows
workforce planning competency management
performance management time and expense
management
education training recruitment
onboarding organizational visualizations
and so
some hcm systems out there would be
success factors from us
from sas the sas hcm
for some reason they they had original
service and then i guess they have a
newer version of the service
workday oracle e-business suite oracle
peoplesoft same thing we're seeing with
sap where they have two sage people and
i don't know how to pronounce it we'll
say uzio
[Music]
so giving a little bit more attention to
the different types of life cycles in
identity governance we're first going to
look at um
identi identity life cycle management
and this is the foundation
of identity governance the goal is to
achieve a balance between productivity
and security
so here we can kind of see an identity
where they have no access they get their
first job their second job and then they
retire so
productivity how quickly can a person
have access to resources they need such
as when they join my organization
security how should their access change
over time such as due to changes
to the person's employment status so
azure ad premium automatically maintains
user identities
for people represented in something like
workday or sap success factors in both
active directory and azure active
directory azure id
azure ad premium also includes microsoft
identity manager
so you can import records from
on-premise hcm systems such as sap
hcm oracle ebusiness or oracle
peoplesoft
azure adb2b collaboration enables you to
securely
share your organization's applications
and services with guest users
and external partners from an
organization while maintaining control
over your corporate data so azure ad
entitlement management
enables you to select which
organizations users
are allowed to request access and to be
added to b2b guests to your organization
directory ensure
these guests are removed when they're no
longer
they no longer need access okay
[Music]
now we looked at identity life cycle now
let's take a look here at
access lifecycle so access lifecycle is
the process of managing user access
throughout the life cycle of an
organization so here
uh you know before we saw that someone
changed jobs well this one has
uh context because they're accessing
something like they have a contract so
there's a particular
set of things that they have to worry
about so azure ad dynamic groups
determine group membership based on user
or device properties
azure ad access reviews enforce review
or on a regular basis to make sure
only the right people have continued
access azure 80 entitlement management
enables you to define
how users request access across packages
of groups and team memberships
application roles sharepoint online
roles okay
so we have one more life cycle here and
this one is privileged access lifecycle
and it is the management of fine grade
permissions over the life cycle of a
user within an organization
so here they might they might start as
an admin then they get their first role
their second role and then they leave it
so
again these are they're also very
similar but they're just a different
scopes
so azure ad privilege identity
management so pim provides additional
controls to securing access rights for
resources across
azure ad azure and other microsoft
online services
and so that's pretty much the only one
that really is related to privileged
access lifecycle okay
[Music]
so entitlement management is a feature
of azure ad and
is for identity governance feature that
enables organizations to manage identity
and access lifecycle at scale
by automating access request workflows
access assignments reviews
and expiration so entitlement management
is a feature of azure ad premium two
it takes a and just to kind of give it a
more simplified uh
understanding what the service does you
take a bunch of resources
bundle them into an access package then
apply it to internal or external users
that for a specific range of time get
just in time access
so you accomplish this by creating a
project catalog and access package
so what is a project inside of
entitlement entitlement management well
it's a logical container for your
catalog and access packages
you have a catalog so resources are
assigned to the project
and resources could be things like
groups and teams applications sharepoint
sites
talking about access packages here an
access package is a bundle of all the
resources with the access
a user needs to work on a project or
perform their task
access packages are used to govern
access for your internal employees and
also users outside your organization
access packages also include one or more
policies a policy defines
the rules or guard rails for assignments
to
access packages for access packages you
can manage group memberships
cloud app access and access rights
sharepoint online sites organizational
and technical
roles
[Music]
so privileged identity management or pim
is an azure ad service enabling you to
manage control and monitor access to
important resources in your organization
you can manage resources from azure id
azure 365
intune and more key features here is
just in time privilege access to azure
id and resources
assign time-bound access to resources
using start and end dates
require approval to activate privileged
roles enforce mfa to activate any role
use justice justification to understand
why users activate
get notifications when privileged rules
are activated conduct
access reviews to ensure users still
need roles download audit history for
internal external audits
so privileged identity management is a
feature of azure 80 premium 2. but to
get kind of an idea like i just pulled
out a little screenshot of the
interface there and so you can see you
have requests and approval requests
and review access so those are some of
the things you're going to be doing in
there okay
[Music]
so identity protection is a feature of
azure id at the p2 level that you can
use to detect investigate
remediate export for future analysis
identity based risks
so microsoft analyzes 6.5 trillion
signals per day
to identify protect customers from
threats so identity protection notices
things like risky users risky sign-ins
and risky detections
so here's an example i know the image is
blurry but it was hard for me to
procure an image for you but um this
example
shows newly risky sign-ins detected over
a period of time
and so then there might be these cards
here that will show you
um you know who are the high risk users
the high resignance the identity score
things like that okay
[Music]
let's take a more granular look to see
what identity protection can actually
detect so
it can look for anomalous ip addresses
so sign ins from anonymous ip addresses
like a tor browser
anomalizer vpns atypical travel
so sign in from a atypical location
based on the user's recent sign-ins
malware linked ip addresses so sign in
from a malware linked ip address
unfamiliar sign in properties to sign in
with properties we've not recently seen
for a given user
leak credentials so it indicates that
the user's valid credentials have may
have been leaked
password spray so multiple user names
being attacked using common passwords in
a unified brute force manner
azure 80 threat intelligence so
microsoft internal external threat
intelligence sources
that have identified a known attack
pattern so maybe new countries so this
detection is discovered by microsoft
cloud app security
activity from anonymous ip addresses so
the detection is discovered by the
microsoft cloud app security so mcas
suspicious inbox forwarding so this
detection is discovered by
microsoft cloud app security so mcas
and the wrist signals can trigger re
remediation efforts such as requiring
users to use azure 80 multi-factor
authentication
reset their password using self-service
password reset so that's
ss pr or blocking or blocking them until
an administrator takes action
[Music]
let's take a look here at investigation
for identity
protection so identity protection
categorized risks into three tiers low
medium and high
so key reports that the admins use for
investigation and identity protection
are risky users risky sign-ins and risky
detections so for risky users
those are details about detections
history of all risky sign-ins
risk history and then for risky risky
sign-ins we have
which risk sign-ins are classified at
risk confirmed compromise confirmed sale
dismissed or remediated
we have real-time and aggregate risk
levels with sign in attempts
detection types triggered conditional
access policies applied mfa details
device apps location information and the
last one here is risk detection
so that contains filterable data for up
to the past 90 days
so we have information about each risk
detection including the type
other risk triggers at the same time
sign in attempt
location link out to more detail for
mcas
so admin follow-up actions reset the
user password confirm user compromise
dismiss user risk
block user from signing in investigate
further
using azure atp
[Music]
so network security groups filter
network traffic to and from the azure
resource
in a v-net and so an nsg is composed of
many security rules
and so here's an example of setting an
inbound security rule
and each security rule has the following
properties so you can give it a
unique name which is all the way at the
bottom there you can set the source or
destination so
you're going to set an ip address cider
block service tag
application group things like that then
you set the port range
so it could just be port 80 it could be
all ports where it shows an asterisk it
could be a range of ports
you can set the protocols you got tcp
udp icmp
you set the action whether it's allowed
or denied and then you set the priority
which is a number between
100 and 4096 and we have two types
of security rules we got inbound rules
which applies to traffic entering the
nsg and outbound rules that apply to
traffic
leaving the nsg
[Music]
let's take a look at some of the default
security rules that nsg sets for you so
when you create an nsg you're going to
have some created for you by default
and that's going to be for outbound
rules and inbound rules so
for inbound rules uh you're going to be
able to uh
accept any virtual networks into your
through the nsg uh it's going to
allow azure load balancer to make its
way in and it's going to deny
everything else all right then for your
outbound rules
it's allowed to go to any other virtual
network it's allowed to make its way out
to the internet and then everything else
is denied so there you go
let's take a look here at the logic for
security rules and there's a lot of
logic here so we'll work our way through
it unfortunately there's no fun way to
visualize this
so we just got to work through the text
so you may not create two security rules
with the same
priority and direction you can have 5000
nsgs per subscription
and 1000 nsg's rules per nsg
for priority rules are processed in
priority order with lowest number
uh processed before the higher number
and network security groups
rules are validated by priority using a
five tuple information to allow or deny
traffic based on source source ports
destination destination ports and
protocol
honestly i don't know what they mean by
that uh and i couldn't
make any sense it's in the documentation
so i'm just showing it to you here
then there's flow records they don't
exactly explain what they are but i
assume
the idea is that uh when a request
throws
flows through the nsg they're attaching
additional information to it
uh so the flow record allows a network
security group to be stateful a flow
record
is created for existing connections
communication is a louder denied based
on the connection state of the flow
record and so let's talk about
statefulness
so if you specify an outbound security
port you don't need to set
the inbound port since it will be set
for you you will need to
specify an inbound security rule if the
communication is
initially externally initiated
externally
and the opposite is also true if inbound
traffic is allowed over report it's not
necessary to specify an outbound
security rule to respond to traffic
over the port uh and the reason i know
this when up
when another port is set with another
one that's when it's stateful if it
didn't do that it would be considered
stateless
but it's stateful let's talk about
interruption so
existing connections may not be
interrupted when you remove a security
rule
that enabled the flow and traffic flows
are interrupted when connections are
stopped and no traffic is flowing in
either direction for at least a few
minutes
so there's the rules uh there's a lot of
stuff there
honestly i won't even remember 90 of
this stuff but i just wanted to go
uh through it with you so there you go
so the thing is is that when you have
network security groups you can apply
them
at the subnet and or the nic and that's
going to change
how the rules work so let's look at
these combination of scenarios so here
we have the internet and let's set
ourselves up
with a virtual machine that has a nick
but it has no network security group so
what's going to happen
in this case well when there is no nsg
assigned to the subnet or nic
then all traffic is allowed uh not
something i recommend i think you should
always have an nsg there
but that's what's going to happen our
next scenario here is that we have a
virtual machine
and then we have a neck and the network
or the network security group is
attached to that neck
so when an nsg is assigned to the nic
and no nsg at the subnet then the rules
are predictable based on the allow or
deny rule so
whatever you set your nsg is what you
expect it to be
then we have a scenario here where we
have two virtual machines with their own
nics
uh and one has a security group and the
other two
uh you know the they have to pass
through the secret group that's applied
the subnet level so let's look at the
one the left first
so the nsg applied to a subnet applies
to the rules
and all the resources in that subnet and
so
basically on the left hand side it's
going to just act like the the other one
there where all the rules you have there
are
are normal but the last one is the
interesting use case
because if the first so the first thing
is the the first nsg rules
are evaluated at the subnet and then the
rules in the nick are evaluated so
the thing is is that if you want port 80
to be open you actually have to open it
on both
otherwise it's going to get stuck uh on
the first one so if your
subnet has port 80 closed and then your
your nic has port 80 open it just can't
reach it so they both have to be open
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the azure network
security group cheat sheet so nsgs
filter network traffic to
and from azure resources v-net an nsg is
composed of many
security rules you have a name a source
and destination a port range and a
protocol and an action a priority
okay you have inbound rules which apply
to
traffic entering the nsg and then you
have outbound rules applying to traffic
leaving the nsg by default azure will
set a bunch of inbound and outbound
rules for you
you may you may not create two security
rules within the same priority and
direction
you can have 5 000 nsgs per subscription
and 1 000 nsgs per
rules per nsg that's a lot you have to
be pretty big company to run out of
those
rules are processed in priority order
with lower numbers processed before
higher numbers the flow record allows a
network security group to be stateful
if you specify an outbound security port
you don't need to set the inbound port
since it will be set for you
the opposite is true if inbound traffic
is allowed over a port it's not
necessary to specify an outbound
security rule to respond to the traffic
over the port what i could not fit in
this cheat sheet was the scenario where
you have multiple
nsgs based on whether they're on the
nick or the virtual machine or et cetera
there is graphics for that in the in the
slides make sure you review those before
you set your exam
okay
[Music]
azure firewall is a managed cloud-based
network security service that protects
azure v-net's resources and it's a fully
stateful firewall as a service so you're
going to get built in high availability
and unrestricted cloud scalability
and what you can do is essentially
create enforce and log
application network connectivity
policies across
subscription and virtual networks so
azure firewall uses a static public ip
address for your vnet resources allowing
outside firewalls to identify or
originating from your virtual network
and the service is fully integrated with
azure monitor
for logging and analytics so here is a
representation
of azure firewall and so the idea is
that you're going to launch an azure
firewall into its own v-net
and then other v-nets and your
on-premise or other things are going to
pass through that central v-net
onto wherever they want to go and the
idea is that
we're going to be able to do things like
utilize microsoft threat intelligence
this is going to block known malicious
ips and
fqdns that it stands for fully qualified
domain names
and by default the traffic is uh set to
deny
but you can set connectivity policies to
filter out traffic in a variety of ways
to make sure that you are protected
uh there so yeah that's all there is to
it
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at ddos so
this stands for distributed denial of
service attack
and it's a malicious attempt to disrupt
normal traffic by flooding a website
with large amounts of fake traffic
so the idea is you have an attacker and
a victim and the attacker is utilizing
a remote machines and uh with a
with some software that's going to
generate out traffic
uh directed towards your virtual machine
over the cloud
and the uh problem here is that what
it's going to do
is it's going to make your website
unresponsive
or just not work at all for the regular
user but by having your
compute within the azure network you're
going to get
free ddos protection and that's going to
mitigate these attacks
so let's talk about the types of ddos
attacks that frequently happen
the first is volumetric attacks so these
are volume-based attacks that flood the
network with legitimate looking traffic
these will exhaust the available
bandwidth and legitimate users cannot
access the website
these are measured in bits per second so
bps
then there are protocol attacks and
these are exhausting server resources
with false
protocol requests that exploit weakness
you're looking at udp and tcp flooding
on the layer three and four
measured in packages per second so psp
then you have application layer attacks
these are attacks that occur at the
application layer uh that's between
layer seven
so you're looking at http floods sql
injection cross site scripting also
known as
xss parameter tamping solaris attacks
here you're going to be wanting using a
waff a web application firewall as a
means of protection
wafts are generally paired a lot a lot
together with ddos
services across the cloud service
provider offerings okay
so azure offers two tiers of ddos
protection the first
is uh the the basic tier this is free
it's already turned on
uh it's part of the global network and
then you have the standard
that starts at about two thousand nine
hundred and uh about three thousand usd
you get metrics alerts reporting ddos
expert support application cost
protections sla
there's probably a difference in terms
of the tier protection i cannot remember
off the top my head but
you know one will protect more likely
against certain types of tax
at like like three and four and the
other one will do all
all the layers three four and seven okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at azure
bastion
which is an intermediate hardened
instance you can use to connect to your
target server
via ssh or rdp an easier way to think of
it it's just a machine that sits between
you and your server
to give you an additional layer of
security so it will provision
a web-based rdp client or ssh terminal
and some devices just cannot run the rdb
client
so this is where a google chromebook uh
is really great fit for azure bastion
because this will be the only way you'd
be able to do it
is through azure bastion so when you
want to make an a bastion you'll have to
create
its own subnet with a very particular
name but some of the key features here
of bastion
is rdp and ssh directly into azure
portal
remote session over tls and firewall
transversal
no public ip required on the azure vm no
hassle managing nsgs
protection against port scanning
protection uh protection against
zero day exploits hardening in one place
only uh so yeah now
if you want to connect to a windows
server you would have to use rdp
and you have to have the bastion in the
same vnet you just enter your username
password as you normally would if you
did rdp so
rdp is remote desktop protocol and
the idea is that you just log in and now
it's like you're using a windows machine
then you have ssh which is for linux and
so the idea here is you'd have your ssh
private key and password that you'd set
when you create your vm
and when you want to hit connect you
just provide either your password or the
private key
and now you're in your server so that's
as simple as astra bastion is
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look here at
azure web application firewall so
uh azure web application firewall also
known as waff
is a service that protects web
application communication on the
application layer that's layer 7
by analyzing incoming http requests uh
waff
for cloud providers are generally
attached to load balancers api gateways
or cdns
so here's kind of a visual um that i got
from the docs but the idea is you have
your
your request it's going to go into your
application load balancer
the waf is attached to the load bouncer
it's going to decide whether it's
allowed to go through or not
so it's kind of a bit of a gatekeeper uh
there okay
so azure waff can be attached to the
azure application gateway
azure front front door which is a cdn
azure con
content delivery network which is a
different kind of cdn
uh and so the idea here is that azure
waff uses core rule sets crs
by owasp to uh protect against common
vulnerabilities if you've never heard of
owasp they stand for open web
application security project
and basically it's an organization a
non-profit organization
and they have all these resources on how
to protect
against different types of threats and
they have basically this top ten
a list of vulnerabilities so that's
probably what they're using here
um but anyway so a wav policy allows you
to apply
manage rules so the azure manager oas
rules and custom rules so there you go
[Music]
all right let's take a look here at the
overview for azure encryption so we have
three options here
for encryption methods the first is
azure storage service encryption
also known as ssc and this protects data
at rest by automatically encrypting
before
persisting it to the azure managed disks
azure blob storage
azure files azure queue storage it also
is used to decrypt data on retrieval
then you have azure disk encryption this
encrypts windows and linux iaas
virtual machine disks it can use
bitlocker features on windows or dmcrypt
on linux
then you have transparent transparent
data encryption
tde which we'll talk about here in a
moment
[Music]
all right so there are two available
encryption options for azure managed
disks the first is server side
encryption ssc
and azure disk encryption ade so for
server-side encryption it provides
encryption at rest and safeguards your
data to meet your organizational
security compliance commitments
it's enabled by default for all the
managed snapshots and images
except for temporary disks which are not
encrypted by server-side encryption
unless you enable encryption at the host
level so keys can be managed
two ways you have platform managed keys
azure managers or keys or customer
managed keys
so you manage your keys then you have
azure disk encryption ade
this allows you to encrypt the os and
data disks used by
uh infrastructure as service vms so for
windows you're going to be using
bitlocker
and for linux encryption you're going to
be using dmcrypt so there you go
[Music]
so transparent data encryption also
known as tde encrypts data rest for
microsoft databases
tde can be applied to sql server azure
sql database azure synapse analytics
and tde does real-time io encryption and
decryption of data and
log files encryption uses a database
encryption key
also known as a dek database
boot record stores the key for
availability during recovery
the dek is a symmetric key so
same cryptographic key uh for both the
encryption or plain text cipher
just an example there so you understand
so the steps to apply to
the database create the database master
key create a certificate to support the
tde
create the database encryption key
enable tde
on the database so you just turn it on
and there you go
let's take a look here at azure key
vault which helps you safeguard
cryptographic keys and other secrets
used by cloud apps and services
so you have secrets management so store
and tightly control access to tokens
password
certificates api keys and other secrets
key management create and control the
encryption keys used to encrypt your
data
certificate management easily provision
manage and deploy public and private ssl
certificates for use
with azure and internal connected
resources and hsm
so secrets and keys can be protected
either by software or a
hardware one which would be fips 140
hyphen 2 level 2 validated hsm
so when we're talking about hsm this is
a hardware security module
it's a piece of hardware designed to
store encryption keys so there's one and
they're really darn expensive you
wouldn't want to buy one out right
it's a lot better if you just kind of
borrow one from the cloud
and this all goes along with the federal
information processing standard fips
this is a u.s and government standard
that specifies security requirements
for cryptographic modules that protect
sensitive information
so hmn's hsms or multi-tenant are
142 hyphen compliant so the multiple
customers virtually isolated on an hsm
if you want a single tenant this is this
will give you fips 140 hive and three
compliance
uh and this is for a single customer
dedicated hsm i believe one is temp
temp tamper evident and the other one is
tamper proof um but
uh yeah so for key vault the the single
tenant is just a separate offering
okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at azure
security benchmarks
so these includes a collection of high
impact security recommendations you can
use to help secure
the services you use in azure include
security controls and service based
lines
so azure security benchmark is a
holistic security guidance
influenced by the cloud adoption
framework the azure well architected
framework
and the microsoft security best
practices so we're talking about
security controls these are
recommendations that are generally
applicable across your azure tenant
and azure services each recommendation
identifies a list of stakeholders that
are typically involved in planning
approval
or implementation of the benchmark then
you have service
based lines so these apply the controls
to individual azure services to provide
recommendations
on that service security configuration
let's take a look here at azure security
center and this is a unified
infrastructure security management
system it strengthens the security
posture of your data centers
provides advanced threat protection
across your hybrid workloads in the
cloud so here
is what it looks like and the idea here
is that you have a regulatory compliance
dashboard
that shows you your compliance posture
for a set of supported standards
regulations based on continuous
assessment
of your azure environment so the
compliance policies currently supported
are the azure security benchmark ppci
dss iso 27001
sock tsp so here you would see
a compliance policy and you can see that
it has 32 out of 40 past controls
if you drill down you could see those
controls in detail
uh then there there's the security score
so security center continually assesses
your resources descriptions and
organization
for security issues it then aggregates
all the findings into a single score
so you can tell at a glance your uh your
current situation
so the higher the score the lower the
identified risk level so there you go
you can see this one is at uh holding at
an 80 percent
the security score helps with
understanding your current security
situation
efficiently and effectively improving
your security the security controls
within
azure security center are used to
calculate the overall score
so security controls are recommendations
of actionable security items
that will help improve your overall
security score so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at
azure security benchmarks if you feel
like you're having deja vu it's because
i covered this
earlier in the course but i wanted to
give it a little bit more attention here
so i
described it in an alternate way here
and digged a little bit deeper all right
so before we can answer what the
security benchmark is let's describe
what a security baseline is so a
security baseline is a set of minimum
security controls
defined for defined for low impact
information systems
moderate impact information systems and
high impact information systems
so security baselines for azure focus on
cloud sensor control area uh control
areas
and these controls are consistent with
well-known security benchmarks such as
described by the center of internet
security cis
so azure security benchmark asb is a
security baseline for azure
and the benchmark is part of a set of
holistic security
guidance that also includes the azure
cloud adoption framework
azure well architected framework and the
microsoft security best practices
so the azure security benchmark has the
following controls and
these are grouped so you have network
security identity management privilege
access data protection asset management
logging threat detection
incident response posture vulnerability
management endpoint security
backup and recovery governance and
strategy and this
whole thing the azure security benchmark
is actually just an excel spreadsheet
that you can download
and what it includes are recommendations
with the following fields so azure
controls
ids recommendations guidance
responsibility
azure security monitor center whether
the azure
security center monitors this control
which is kind of weird because when i
actually opened it up
these fields didn't exactly match one to
one
but i do i did pull out one in
particular for us so we can see what it
looks like so
they'll have general guidance here so
notice that they're just kind of like
describing it so they're just saying
what it can do and then we have some
links and notice that it's linking to um
i'm not sure which stock this is but
when they talked about those three uh
resources that's what they talk about
when they're saying that
they're influenced by those three for
azure control this would be the asset
management then it has its id
uh then there are um uh cis controls so
like these or nist controls so the idea
is they're saying like yeah we
have this control in our system but they
map over to these
well-known ones so you know you can
trust them uh then there's the
benchmark recommendation uh then there's
responsibility so here's this
customer and then there's customer
stakeholders um
and that points over to the cloud
adoption framework so uh you know you
can open it up and give it a read it's
not super fun
uh but this pretty much is the gist of
it okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look here at azure
defenders so azure defender provides
advanced protection for your azure and
on-premise workloads
and azure defender can be found in the
azure security center so
within the security center there'll be a
tab called azure defender and that's the
way you find it so azure defender is
composed of coverage
security alerts insights and advanced
protection so talking about coverage
it allows you to see the resource types
that are in your subscription and
eligible for protection by azure
defender
so here take note that we can see things
like virtual machines kubernetes
services container registry app services
sql vms vault key vaults
sql servers and storage accounts for
security alerts
they describe details of the affected
resources such as remediation steps
and in some cases an option to trigger a
logic app in response
so here you can kind of see security
alerts over time
then there are insights this is a
rolling pane of news suggested reading
and high priority alerts
that give security centers insights into
pressing security matters
that are relevant to you and your
subscription for advanced protection
within defender are additional security
features that is driven by analytics so
vm vulnerability assessments
just-in-time vm access adaptive
application control
container image scanning adaptive
network hardening sql vulnerability
assessment
file integrity monitoring network map
iot security and so down below
you can see all these options here
whether they're turned on or not let's
take a we'll take a look at network map
here in a moment
so scope of azure defender so it has a
lot of different plans for specific
azure resources
so we have azure defender for servers
app service storage
sql kubernetes container registry key
vault resource manager
dns open source relational databases and
when you turn on azure defender all
plans are activated
we saw that under the advanced
protection tabs
then just to kind of highlight network
map because this one's really cool
it's a network map that provides a
graphical graphical view
with security overlays giving you
recommendations and insights for
hardening your network resources so
using the map you can see the network
topology of your azure workloads
uh connections between your virtual
machines and subnets and the
capabilities to drill down
from the map into a specific resource
resources and the recommendations of
those resources
and then just the last thing i want to
touch on here is hybrid cloud protection
so azure defender can protect vms
residing in other cloud service
providers such as aws
and gcp via azure arc so azure arc if
you've never heard of it is a control
plane
that can manage compute resources across
cloud service providers on premise
and at the stage or at the edge and so
for infrastructure you'll notice that it
can handle
vms uh kubernetes clusters sql servers
and azure stack hcis
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at azure
sentinel so
azure sentinel is a scalable cloud
native security information event
management so
siem and security orchestration
automated response so
s-o-a-r a soar so azure sentinel
delivers intelligent security analytics
and threat intelligence across the
enterprise providing a single solution
for alert detection threat visibility uh
proactive hunting
and threat response so uh here's the big
old wheel that
azure sentinel likes to use to describe
it and what's cool about this offering
is it's both an siem
and a source so you don't have to have
two separate services
talking about collect first so collect
data at cloud scale across all users
devices applications and infrastructure
both on premise and in multiple clouds
detect previously undetected threats and
minimize false positives using microsoft
analytics unparalleled threat
intelligence
investigate threats with artificial
intelligence and hunt for suspicious
activities at scale tapping into years
of cybersecurity work at microsoft
respond to incidents rapidly with
built-in orchestration and automation of
common tasks
[Music]
let's take a look at what azure sentinel
can actually
ingest from other data sources so we
have a number of connectors here such as
microsoft 365 defender office 365 or
microsoft 365 that's how they like to
call it now
azure ad microsoft defender for identity
microsoft
cloud app security and common event
formats would be syslog
rest api windows event logs common event
format so
cef and trusted automated exchange for
indicator information
or also known as taxi
[Music]
let's take a look here at azure
workbooks and this is really a feature
of azure monitor but azure central
allows you to create workbooks really
easily so workbooks provide a flexible
canvas for data analysis
and creation of rich visual reports
within the azure portal they allow you
to tap into multiple data sources from
across azure and combine them into
unified interactive experiences
it tells a story about the performance
and availability about your applications
and services
so here's a big funny graph and uh
here's another one but the idea is that
these are kind of like living documents
where you can
uh visualize monitoring stuff
with like written text and visuals so
workbooks are temporary workspaces to
find a document like format
with visualizations intertwined to help
investigate
and discuss performance if you've ever
used jupyter notebooks it's kind of
similar but for logging
[Music]
all right so let's take a look at some
of the core features of azure sentinel
so i'm just going to go through a bunch
of them here so let's get to it
so azure sentinel uses analytics to
correlate alerts into incidents
so over here we can see that we have a
list of them and incidents
are groups of related alerts that
together create an actionable possible
threat
that you can investigate and resolve
then there's automation
orchestration so with sentinel you have
solutions that provide a highly
extensible
architecture that enables scalable
automation as new technologies and
threat emerge
and this is just using azure logic apps
so it's a great way of
not having to use any code but you can
chain things over
into different services and they have
over 200 connectors there's a lot you
can do here
for investigations the investigation
tools help you
understand the scope and find the root
cause
of a potential security threat and you
can choose an entity on the
interaction graph to ask interesting
questions for a specific entity
and drill down into that entity and its
connections to get
to the root cause that's root cause
analysis should wrote that in there for
you
for hunting so azure sentinel's
powerful hunting search query based
tools is based on the miter framework
now you know why i covered that earlier
which enables you to proactively hunt
for security threats
across your organizational data sources
before an alert is triggered
after you discover which hunting query
provides high value insights
into the possible tax you can create
custom detection rules based on your
query
and service those insights as alerts to
your security instance
responders while hunting you can create
bookmarks from interesting events
enabling you to return them later
share them with others and group them
with other coordinating events to
create compelling incident
investigations so there you go
[Music]
so just a quick description here of
azure sentinel pricing so it has two
pricing models capacity reservation
this is build a fixed fee based on the
selected tier enabling a predictive
total cost for azure sentinel
and pay as you go so build per gigabyte
for the volume of data ingested for
analysis in azure sentinel
and stored in azure monitored log
analytics workspace
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we are looking at microsoft
365 so it was formerly known as office
365 but you'll see me refer to it as
office 365 because everyone's used to
with that
but it is a suite of business software
packaged as
soft as a sas offering so there are
a bunch of services you probably
recognize quite a few of them and you
can access it
at the portal.office.com most notable
services would be sharepoint so it's a
site collaboration shared company
document drive
outlook that's an email service word
processor which is word
powerpoint that's slideshows excel
that's spreadsheets teams collaboration
app for your organizations
similar to slack so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at
microsoft 365 defender
which is unified pre and post breach
enterprise defense suite
the natalie natively coordinates
responses such as detection prevention
investigation across endpoints
identities emails and applications to
provide integrated
protection against sophisticated attacks
so if you're looking for where the
service is you'd open up
portal.office.com you look at the um
the side menu and you're clicking on
security that is where
you will find microsoft 365 defender so
defender is composed of the following
services
it has a secure score uh endpoint uh
it's for office 365 identity app
security
uh and so that's just kind of a graphic
to reiterate over those four
okay
[Music]
so within microsoft 365 defender you get
a secure score and this is a
representation of your organization's
security posture
and your opportunity to improve it via
improvement action so
this is very similar to azure defenders
secure score they just
have a slightly different terminology to
make it a little bit more
uh company friendly people that aren't
developers but
over here we have the secure score and
then you see the improvement actions
looks very similar to what we saw before
[Music]
so within microsoft 365 we have
endpoints and these are a set of
destination ip addresses
dns domain names and urls for microsoft
365 traffic on the internet
so to optimize performance for m365
cloud-based services these endpoints
need special handling by client browsers
and the devices in your edge network
and these devices include firewalls ssl
brakes
and inspect packet inspection devices
and data loss protection dlp
system so this is what it looks like
again it's just
ip addresses and dns domains so
endpoints are grouped into four service
areas exchange online sharepoint online
and onedrive for business
skype for business online and microsoft
teams
and uh m365 common office online so it's
just a bunch of these things here on the
left hand side
but this specialized for those
particular areas so now taking a look
here at microsoft defender for endpoint
is an enterprise
endpoint security platform designed to
help enterprise networks prevent detect
investigate and respond to advanced
threats
and so defender for endpoint uses the
following combination of technology
built into windows 10 and microsoft
cloud
service so we have endpoint behavioral
sensors so embedded in windows 10
these sensors collect and process
behavioral signals
from os and send this sensor data to
your private isolated
cloud instances of microsoft defender
for endpoint then you have cloud
security analytics
so this is leveraging big data device
learning and unique microsoft optic
optics across the windows ecosystem
enterprise cloud products such as office
365
and online assets behavioral signals are
translated into insights
detections and recommended responses to
advanced threats
then we have threat intelligence this is
generated by microsoft hunters security
teams and augmented by
by threat intelligence providers by
partners threat intelligence enables
defender for endpoint to identify attack
attacker tools techniques procedures and
generate alerts when they are observed
in collected sensor
data
[Music]
so within microsoft 365 defender you
have security reports and these are
general security dashboards about
security trends for m365 identities
device and apps
information is organized into cards on
the dashboard so you have identities
where we'll have users at risk and
global admins then you have devices so
devices at risk device compliance
devices with active malware
types of malware on devices malware on
devices
devices with malware detection users
with malware detection
then you have apps which have risk
levels and so
all this information can be reorganized
so right now we have identities devices
and apps
but we could also have risk detection
threads and configuration health so just
to kind of tell you a little bit
more here it's just imagine you have a
bunch of these cards and they're broken
down by
all these categories here so you can
have a bird's eye view of what's going
on
okay one particular report that is
interesting to show you
is the office 625 exchange one so this
is email collaboration reports
so just kind of gives you statistics
over time so that's a viewer to drill
down into
a particular type of report here um and
so you can kind of see things like
you know spam detection over time spoof
detection things like that okay
so m365 defender for identity is a
cloud-based security solution that
leverages your on-premise active
directory signals to identify detect and
investigate advanced threats
compromise identities and malicious
insider actions directed at your
organization
it detects advanced attacks in hybrid
environments to monitor users
entity behaviors and activities with
learning based analytics protect
user identities and credentials and
stored in active directory
identify investigate suspicious user
activities and advanced attacks
throughout the kill chain
provide clear incident information on
simple timeline for fast triage
i had the hardest time trying to find
any kind of screenshot for this
and i just kind of gave up so i mean you
have the gist of it but it's nice to
have a visual you know
so microsoft defender for identity
monitors your domain controllers by
capturing and parsing network traffic
and leveraging windows events directly
from your domain controllers
then analyzes the data for attacks and
threats so here is kind of the
architecture of it
so you know we have our domain
controller over here
then we have microsoft defender identity
and then it's going to go to
our cas mcas so that we can do some
analysis and stuff
later on and you could pass it off over
to your siem
or azure sentinel and things like that
so utilizing profiling deterministic
detection machine learning behavioral
algorithms defender for identity
learns about your network enables
detection of for anomalies and warns you
of suspicious
activities
[Music]
so microsoft defender for office 365
protects against advanced threats by
email messages
links teams sharepoint onedrive for
business and other
clients and protection is provided via
reports threat investigations
thread responses threat protection
policies and there's three available
subscriptions we have the
exchange online protection the defender
for
office 365 plan one and plan two
and office 365 security builds on the
core protections offered by eop so eop
is present in
any subscription where exchange online
mailboxes
can be found so go in more detail here
for eop
cloud-based filtering service that
protects your organizations against spam
malware and other email threats
defender office p1 safe attachments
checks email attachments for malicious
content
safe links links are scanned for each
click a safe link remains accessible but
malicious links are blocked
protection for sharepoint onedrive
microsoft teams identifies and blocks
malicious files in team sites
and document libraries anti-phishing
protection so it detects
attempts to impersonate your users
internal or custom domains
real-time detection a real-time report
that allows you to identify and analyze
recent threats
for defender for office p2 i don't know
why i didn't highlight that one that's
how it goes includes defender office p1
features
so we have threat trackers latest
intelligence on cyber security issues
takes counter measurements before an
actual threat threat explorer so
real-time reports that allows you to
identify and analyze recent threats
automated investigation and response
also known as air
is a set of security playbooks that can
be launched automatically
start an automatic investigation provide
detailed reports recommend
action security teams can can approve
i'm describing what a playbook is there
so attack simulator so run realistic
attack scenarios in your organization to
identify
vulnerabilities so you can see that p2
is very very good
a bit more detail on the eop here
is an on is a cloud-based filtering
service that protects
your organization from spam malware and
other email threats i know we just said
it but here is kind of the graphic
and so this has features for
anti-malware inbound anti-spam
outbound spam connection filtering
anti-fishing anti-spoofing
zero hour auto purge zap for delivered
malware spam and phishing messages
preset security policies
10 allow block list allow block lists
for message
senders directory based edge blocking so
dbeb
mail flow rules accepted domains message
training and more i just couldn't fit
them all in the screen but i just wanted
to show you
how valuable uh exchange online
protection is and that's one reason why
you don't want to be using
i mean you could but like this is one of
the advantages of
exchange over gmail okay
[Music]
so microsoft cloud app security mcas is
a cloud access security broker
so casb that sits between the user and
the cloud
service provider to gateway access in
real time to cloud services
if you're getting tired of the
initialisms so am i because there's just
so many
mcas is built on top of the four
principles of the microsoft cloud app
security framework
discover and control the the use of
shadow i.t
so identify cloud apps ias pass
services used by your organization
investigate usage patterns
uh patterns assess uh and risk levels
assesses and risk
levels and business readiness for more
than 16 000 sas
apps against more than 80 risks starts
managing them to ensure security and
compliance then you have protect your
sensitive information anywhere in the
cloud
understand classify protect the exposure
of sensitive information at rest
leverage out the box policies and
automated
processes to apply control in real time
across all cloud apps
protect against cyber threats and
anomalies to detect unusual behavior
across cloud apps
to identify ransomware compromise
croppers users or rogue applications
analyze high risk usage and remediate
automatically to limit the
risks to your organization assess the
compliance of your cloud apps
so assesses if your cloud app meets
relevant compliance requirements
including regulatory compliance and
industry standards prevent data leaks to
com non-compliant apps
and limit access to regulated data more
information
we're not done cloud app security
integrates visibly with your cloud by
uh using cloud discovery to map and
identify your cloud environment and the
cloud apps
using your organization so just take
note over here
okay sanctioning and unsanctioning
apps in your cloud using easy to deploy
app connectors
that take advantage of provider apis for
visibility governments of your apps that
you connect to
using conditional access uh
app control protection to gain real time
visibility
and control over access and activities
within your cloud apps helping you have
continuous control by setting and then
continually fine-tuning policies
office 365 cloud app security is a
subset of microsoft
cloud app security so there is a variant
here for us
and this has threat protection based on
user activity logs discover shadow it
for apps with similar functionality to
office 625 offering
yeah get this for no extra cost if you
have azure premium
one okay
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look here at
microsoft endpoint manager so
microsoft intune and configuration
manager were two separate products and
they were merged into a single service
called microsoft endpoint manager
because they're so darn similar
but they had different product uh
marketing all this stuff and just got
really confusing so they just rolled it
into one
so microsoft intune is used for managing
the security of mobile devices
configuration manager is used to manage
desktop servers and laptops
this can all be accessed via the
endpoint.microsoft.com
that's where the microsoft endpoint
manager admin center is
we'll just talk about intune
configuration manager is pretty similar
so we don't need to
go into details about that but microsoft
intune is a mobile device and mobile
application manager
so mdm mam found within the microsoft
endpoint manager so it can manage
devices
manage security baselines use policies
to manage device security
use device compliance policies configure
conditional access
integration with microsoft defender
endpoint role-based access controls
and it integrates with azure id mobile
threat defenders
admx templates win32 custom
lob apps uh and more so microsoft intune
can be used to manage on-premise
infrastructure via
in-tune connectors which i think that's
pretty cool intune connectors for
active directory intune certificate
certificate connector
and there we go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the concept of
regulatory compliance so what is
compliance it's conforming to rules such
as a specification policy standard or
law
and regulatory compliance is an
organization that takes an
effort to comply with relevant laws
policies and regulations
so regulatory compliance can vary at the
following level so federal
state political and economic union an
international organization so why do we
have regulatory compliance will
governments want to protect its citizens
data that is collected by companies and
organizations what are compliance
controls well those are internal control
mechanisms that need to be in place to
detect prevent
and correct compliance issues so public
standards and policies
document procedures uh training
monitoring
internal audits so what can uh they do
to
enforce these things so they have or the
idea is why
like what will the measures of
regulatory compliance enforce so
citizens
get the right to access their data
anytime the right to correct or uh or
delete their data if needed
retention periods that for a minimum or
maximum time
data should be stored enabling
governments and regulatory agencies the
right to access and examine data when
necessary
defining rules for what data can be
processed and how
that should be done okay
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're going to take a look here at
the m365 compliance center so this
provides easy access to data and tools
that you need to manage your
organizational compliance needs so here
is a screenshot
and the way you get there is
compliance.microsoft.com
sometimes these things are hard to find
so you got to know what these domains
are so some of the features here would
be compliance score audits activity
alerts solution catalog data
classification
ediscovery insider risk management
records management and that is not the
definitive list there's a lot of stuff
in here
uh don't worry we are going to spend
quite a bit of time around compliance
center in this course so
you know we're going to dive deeper on
some of these things if you want to
access compliance center you need to be
either a global administrator
compliance administrator or a compliance
data administrator
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at the
azure trust center and this is a public
public-facing website
portal providing easy access to privacy
security regulatory compliance
information
so yeah it's just a simple website but
one of the cool features here is audit
reports so audit reports
is an independent audit report for
microsoft cloud services which provides
information about
compliance with data protection
standards and regulatory requirements so
you'll get reports for iso
sock nist fedramp gdpr and so you got a
big old
list there of docs and pdfs you can
download you can open them up and then
see how microsoft and azure is being
compliant
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro
we're going to take a look here at
compliance manager so this is an at a
glance summary for of the shared
responsibility model for microsoft
and your organization now i got a bit
confused because i use it in one place
and then i found it somewhere else but
it turns out there's two versions of
this
there's one in the microsoft trust
center or azure trust center
which is the classic compliance manager
and then there's the m365 compliance
center the
compliance manager the screenshots here
from the classic but the information is
the same okay
so risk assessment workflow and
management tools is one of the things
you get with this so provides task
assignment and verification to help
governance risk compliance teams and i t
departments work together
to streamline internal compliance
activities you get intelligent tracking
this understands common similar
compliance activities across
multiple standards and regulations to
reduce your organization costs
and efforts from regulation to audit by
applying a single activity to multiple
assessments or controls
each uh each assessed control will be
labeled preventative detective
or corrective and will be mandatory or
discretionary
as assessments for gdpr nist and iso for
office 365 for azure we have gdpr
iso 27 18 and then 2701
and hipaa and so this is what it kind of
looks like here is uh the card that
shows the compliance you have a
compliance score
now i imagine and maybe we'll look at
this moment but m365 compliance center
will be all around
m365 assets and maybe the classic one
combines both azure and microsoft
but we'll have to investigate that so
clicking into an assessment will give
you a detailed list of actionable
controls so here you see the controls
and it has a score and you can assign it
to someone and etc so
yeah there you go
[Music]
okay since compliance manager has two
variants i figured just to avoid
confusion we should take a closer look
at it
here i have the microsoft 65 compliance
center open
at the top here you see compliance
manager and so you have an overview
improvement action solution so here you
can see a compliance score
and then here it has the improved
actions these are really slow loadings i
just opened another tab here
so down below you can see the
improvement actions
um you know they generally look the same
you can assign it to a user et cetera
i don't know what we get if we click
into it let's take a look
again very slow loading um yeah so how
to implement and then
more information you can make implement
implementation notes
they have testing standard regulation
documents so there's stuff you can do
here to
collect an audit to make sure that you
are doing what you're supposed to be
doing over in the
service trust center you can drop it
down you see classic compliance manager
this is where we just were
so for classic you'd connect it to your
azure account
just scroll down you'd see these cards
here so you can click into a card
and just expand it and see what kind of
things you need to do there so
there you go that is the two variants of
compliance manager
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at
compliance programs and so there's a lot
of different ones
uh that are for azure but i figured we
should go through some of them so
you get a bit more familiarity with this
same stuff we covered in the az900 but
if you didn't take that certification
this is a great opportunity to
see them firsthand okay so the first one
here is the criminal justice information
services
this stands for uh this initialism here
is cjis
so any state or local agency that wants
access to the fbi's
database is required to adhere to the
cjis
security policy then you have the cloud
security alliance csa star certification
this is an
independent third party assessment of a
cloud provider security
posture then you have the gdpr this is a
european privacy law imposes new rules
on companies governments agencies
non-profits and other orgs
that offer goods and services to people
in the european union or that
collect analyze data tied to eu
residents
this one is a very well known one
because even if you don't live in the eu
you still basically have to enforce this
on your website this goes for everybody
which is if people want to uh delete
their data they should be able to they
should know what kind of data is being
collected et cetera
we have the eu model clauses this is the
contractual guarantees around transfers
of personal data outside the eu
you have hipaa so this is a u.s federal
law that regulates patient protected
health information
you have the iso 27018 this is a code of
practice covering the processing of
personal information by cloud service
providers
you have um multi-tier cloud security
uh this is operational singapore
security management standard
it's a common center that that cloud
service providers can apply to address
customer concerns about security and
confidence
confidential uh ality of data in the
cloud and impact of business
of using cloud services then you have
socks service
organization controls there's sock one
two and three
so these are independent third party
examination reports that demonstrate how
the
company achieves key compliance controls
and objectives
generally tech companies are going for
sock to compliance
um so we'll go into the next section
here we have nist
cyber security framework this is a
voluntary framework that consists of
standards guidelines and best practices
to manage cyber security related risks
then you have like government specific
ones so like there's one for canada
there's one for all sorts of countries
but this is a uk specific
one it's called g cloud and it's a cloud
computing certification for services
used by government entities in the
united kingdom
and then you have fips so federal
information processing standard this is
a u.s and canada government standard
that specifies specifies the security
requirements for cryptographic modules
that protect sensitive information
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at microsoft
information protection also known as mip
and this is a collection of features
within m365 compliance to help you
discover classify
and protect sensitive information
wherever it travels or
resides so the idea here is that we have
this diagram and we have a four specific
domains
of things around our data and so the
first is know your data the second is
protect your data
the third is prevent data loss and the
fourth is govern your data
which will be its own category here is
kind of part of it
so we'll get into it next okay
[Music]
all right so let's look at the three of
the four domains here for the microsoft
information protection these are
features
found within the microsoft compliance
center
so the first is know your data
understand your data landscape and
identify
important data across your hybrid
environment so one feature would be
sensitive information types
so identify sensitive data by using
built-in or custom regular expressions
or a function
uh corroborative evidence includes
keywords confidence levels and proximity
we have built-in sensitive labels then
there's um
and you have custom ones probably as
well yeah so then there's train
uh trainable classifiers so these
identify sense of data by using examples
of the data
you're interested in rather than
identifying elements in the item so
pattern matching
and you can use built-in classifiers or
train a classifier with your own content
so you have trainable classifiers here
for data classification this is a
graphical identification of items in
your organization
that have a sensitive label a retention
label or have been classified
you can also use this information to
gain insights into the actions
that that your users are taking uh
taking on these items so that's the
content explorer
the activity explorer all of these three
features we will look at in granular
detail okay so don't worry if they don't
make sense right now
the second part is protect your data so
apply flexible protection
actions that include encryption access
restriction and visual markings
so sensitivity labels the azure
information protection unified labeling
client
double key encryption office 365 message
encryption
uh service encryption with customer key
sharepoint information rights management
irm
rights management connector azure
information protection unified labeling
scanner
microsoft cloud app security microsoft
information protection sdk
most of these you don't need to know but
we will definitely cover sensitivity
labels that's for sure
then we have prevent data loss so these
prevent accidental over
sharing of sensitive information so that
would be dlps
endpoint data loss protection there is a
chrome extension that does uh compliance
compliance for you so it's built into
your browser the m365 data loss
prevention for on-premise scanner
protection sensitive
information in microsoft teams chat
channel channels messages
we'll probably look at a more closer
look at the last one there okay
[Music]
all right so out of the four domains
the the last one here is for governance
and this one particular one is actually
more of a subset and so that's why we
give it the microsoft information
governance title here mig
and it is a collection of features to
govern your data for compliance or
regulatory they have this nice graphic
here to kind of show the scope
of this here but we'll first talk about
information governance
so this is retention policies and
retention labels import service
archive third party data inactive
mailboxes and then you have records
management this is a single solution for
email documents
that incorporates retention schedules
and requirements in a file plan that
supports the full life cycle of your
content with records
declaration retention and disposition
[Music]
so sensitive information types are
classifications or categories of data by
sensitivity so within the m365
compliance
data classification feature you can get
a breakdown of the distribution of
sensitive info types
so here imagine you have a bunch of
documents and you said hey tell me what
you found in these documents and there
it gives it kind of a breakdown
these types of identified base these are
identified based on regular expressions
or a function
and there's hundreds of built-in uh
information types so ip address
eu passport number credit card number
azure storage account key aba routing
number
canada health service number latvian
driver
license number netherlands tax
identification number so it's a huge
list
these are used the sensitive information
types are used in data loss retention so
dlp policies
sensitive labels retention labels
insider risk management
communication compliance auto labeling
policies generally the first thing
you're going to do with your data
classification is
get your sensitive information types
okay and you can create your own too
so if there's something that doesn't
meet your needs you'll have to write
your own regular expression but you can
have whatever you want okay
[Music]
another feature found in data
classification within the
m365 compliance center are trainable
classifiers
let's talk about what training is and
classifiers are so a classifier is a
machine learning model that can take
records of data and classify
categorize by applying a label from a
predetermined
list of categories then you have
training and this is the active teaching
and machine learning model how to learn
by providing it large amounts of data
that is already labeled
it uses the label data to tell if its
predictions are similar to the ones
provided so
within m365 compliance center there are
two kinds of trainable classifiers
pre-trained classifiers so ready to use
classifiers with five pre-trained
classifiers we'll talk about those five
in a moment
you don't need to provide any data used
for training meets any general use cases
and you have custom trainable
classifiers
when you have your own kind of documents
when you have specific business
requirements
but you'll have to provide the training
data so the five are resumes source code
harassment profanity and threat
so here they are in the actual service
itself okay
[Music]
another feature in the data
classification within m365
compliance center is content explorer so
this is a drill down to find
emails or documents that have been
labeled based on sensitive information
types
sensitivity labels or retention labels
so the idea here
is you have broad categories on the left
hand side where it says sensitive do you
see the three categories information
types labels and retention labels let me
get out my pen here
over here all right and then what you'll
do is click into one
and then they'll have more or specific
actual items underneath and you'd click
into one of those and then from there
you can go
and it's on the right hand pane over
here which is this you can go
and explore uh different documents and
files to
identify that kind of information okay
the other explorer here is the activity
explorer and this helps discover which
file labels were changed and which files
were modified so
monitors label activity cross exchange
sharepoint onedrive endpoint devices
so here is a great visual just to get an
idea
so here you have filter so activity
location user
the type of filter you want and then you
can just see so see it says labeled
applied here so you can see that these
labels were applied
this gray is for files created files
copy the cloud is a little orange here
uh we have the green false copied to
removable media is over here in the
green
so you get an idea of what this does
okay
so sensitivity labels allow you to apply
a label to your document
or email and the most common way is via
built-in drop-downs within office 365
products i actually tried
using these but i guess i'd have to do a
lot of setup to get these and so
i i just had to grab previously existing
screenshots but
here's one for word here's one for excel
and here's
one from outlook so the idea is that you
do do your business as per
usual but you'd have to go ahead and
classify
that information into a particular
sensitivity okay
so sensitivity labeling makes it easy to
apply uh
or to do content marketing or encryption
so content marking it would be like
watermarks or warnings that are applied
to the header and footer of a document
so notice here you know you turn it on
and you can say add this watermark with
this customized text add this header add
this footer
i think you can even customize some of
the colors very limited but it does the
job okay
the other one is encryption so apply
encryption and specify which users and
groups may decrypt
and other fine-tune permissions so the
idea is you would turn the encryption on
then you would select the users groups
or etc who could do it
then they have these broad categories
and so this
particular one is for email but here you
can see that you know
are you allowed to afford the email are
you allowed to reply to the email can
you save the email are you allowed to
view it so it's very fine-tuned
it's not just encryption even though
that's what it's called
so within the m365 compliance center
under classifications you can see the
distribution of sensitive labels applied
to documents
and emails or based on location so this
gives you a visual as to understanding
like where these labels are
so here on the left-hand side is what
has been applied and then here is where
they are all right
so sensitive labels can be used in
providing protection settings that
include encryption
and content markings protect content in
office apps across different platforms
and devices
protect content in third-party apps and
services protect containers
extend sensitive sensitivity labels to
power bi
extend sensitivity labels to assets in
azure extend sensitivity labels to
third-party apps and services
and classify content without using any
protection settings
[Music]
let's take a look here at label policies
for sensitivity labels so in order to
use sensitivity labels they need to be
published alongside a label policy
so a label policy determines who can use
the label
and other conditions so the idea is you
say okay well
which users can use these labels
and then here are some of the settings
here so notice below i'm going to get my
pen out here so
users must provide justification to
remove a label or lower classification
requires user to apply a label to the
email or document
provides user with a link to a custom
help page
so choose the users and groups that the
label can see so labels
can be published to specific users
distribution groups
m365 groups and azure ad and more
so you apply default label a label to
all the new emails and documents that
can be specified
for users and groups to create users can
always change the default label if they
believe the document or email has been
mislabeled
required justifications for label
changes so if a user wants to remove a
label or repeat it
admins can require the user to provide a
valid justification to complete the
action the user will be
prompted to provide an explanation for
why the label should be changed then we
have require user to apply a label some
mandatory
mandatory labeling it ensures a label is
applied before users can save the
documents
send emails or create new sites or
groups and we have link users to custom
help pages so it helps users
to understand what the different
different labels mean
and how they should be used
[Music]
let's take a look at retention labels
and retention policies so retention
labels ensure
data is held for a specific duration to
meet a regulatory compliance
or industry best practice and retention
policies are used to assign the same
retention settings
to content at the site level or mailbox
level and we do have some nice visuals
uh there
the first one at the top just getting my
pen out here top
retention labels applied to content and
then the locations of those labels
not too different from sensitivity
labels that's why we didn't have to
spend too much time on it but it's
pretty clear you're just holding on to
data for a particular amount of time
[Music]
so what is records management well this
is when an organization's process of
managing
uh their information throughout its life
cycle and record management helps
organizations meet regulatory compliance
legal requirements
so a life cycle of a record would look
something like identifying classifying
storing securing retrieving tracking
destroying
and preserving and so a record
represents labeled information or
content
and it's life cycle to be managed so
within the n365 compliance center
you have record management and this
enables you to do label content as a
record
migrating managing retention plans and
with file
plan manager establishing retention and
deletion policies within the record
label
triggering event-based retention
reviewing validating disposition
proof of record deletion exporting
information about disposed
items setting specific permissions for
record manager functions and
organizations
for label content applies to the
following so restrictions are put in
place to block certain activities
activities are logged proof of
disposition is kept at the end of the
retention period
i could not find any screenshots for
this and it was so hard to figure out
how to even
see it myself so i'm sorry but uh we're
gonna have to deal with text for this
okay
so within m365 compliance center they
have data loss protection dlp
policies that prevent data loss so dlp
policies allow you to
identify and monitor and automatically
protect sensitive information m365
help users learn how compliance works
view dlp
reports glp policies are composed of
conditions so these are matching content
before the rules enforced
actions this is what action to take when
the condition is found
locations where the policy should be
applied all right so
not too complicated but there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at insider
risk management and so this is another
service that's underneath the m365
compliance center
so insider risk management minimizes
internal risks by enabling you to detect
investigate and act on malicious and
inadvertent activities
in your organization so define the types
of risk to identify detecting
organization
including acting on cases and escalating
cases to the microsoft advance
e-discovery if needed so insight risk
management is looking to detect
leaks of sensitive data and data
spillage confidentiality
violations ip theft fraud
insider trading regulatory compliance
violations and so over here on the right
we have the actual workflow for it and
notice it is policy alerts triage
investigate action
the last three being all tied to an
insider risk case and so
the features we're going to cover
literally maps to this workflow here
these five things let's jump into it
first looking at policies
so policies are predefined templates and
policy conditions that define
what triggering events and risk
indicators are examined in your
organization so
here's the here's the page itself you
see you have warnings recommendations
and policies and down below
are your defined policies and we can
drill down into those
well we'll be able to set alerts on them
that's when they're talking about
triggering events
we're talking about alerts and so that's
the next step here so alerts
automatically generated by risk
indicators
that match policy conditions and are
displayed in the alerts
dashboard and so we can identify the
status of an existing alerts and new
alerts that need actions such as status
severity time detected case and case
status so down below
you'll see the status the activity sense
activity severity the case that it's
part of the case status all right
because these get grouped into case
which we'll talk about here in a moment
but if we want to uh dig deeper we can
click in any
into any of these alerts and this is
where we're going to get triage so this
allows reviewers uh
to see detailed information about the
activities identified within a policy
and the user activity associated with
the policy that was matched so you'll be
able to see the severity alert and
review the user profile information so
it's a bit more information here but
what's going to be really useful
is actually investigate because that is
a holistic view
of all the alerts and information that
have been tied under a case so the case
dashboard provides an all-up view of all
active cases
open cases over time and case statistics
for organization
reviewers can quickly filter case by
study and the date the case was opened
and the date the case was last
updated cases are created for alerts
that require deeper review and
investigation of the activity details
and the circumstances around the policy
match so the primary investigation tools
are user activity
activity explorer content explorer and
case notes so there you go
[Music]
another service that's within the m365
compliance center there's a lot of them
in there
is communication compliance and that
helps minimize communication risks
by helping you detect capture and act on
inappropriate messages in your
organization so
you have predefined and custom policies
that allow you to scan internal and
external communications
for policy matches so they can be
examined by designated reviewers
reviewers can investigate scanned email
microsoft teams yammer or third-party
communications in your organization and
take appropriate action to make sure
they're compliant with your
organization's message standards
so communication compliance can uh can
scan increasing types of communication
channels increasing the volume of
message data regulatory enforcement of
the risk of fines
scenarios of communication compliance
could be corporate policies so like
acceptable use and ethical standards
avoiding harassment or use of
inappropriate offensive language
then there's risk management so manage
potential legal exposure and risk
under authorized communications and
conflicts of interest about confidential
projects such as upcoming acquisitions
mergers earnings disclosures
reorganizations leader
leadership team changes regulatory
compliance so
supervisory or oversight process of
messaging
that's inappropriate for the industry
regulatory authority
this one again it's hard to get
screenshots of these services because
they all
require you to have trial and full
information and microsoft was pretty
sparse on this but this service does a
lot but when you look at it it doesn't
seem like it does
okay so it has this little workflow here
where we have configure investigate and
then
there's the continuous monitoring so
we'll quickly go through here so
configure is identify your compliance
requirements
and configure application or applicable
communication compliance policies
so offensive or threatening language
sensitive information regulatory
compliance conflict of interest
custom policy for investigate issues
detected as matching your communication
compliance policies alerts issue
management document review
reviewing user activity history filters
so for remediate you have remediate
communication compliance issues you've
investigated to resolve
tag a message notify the user escalate
to another reviewer
mark as a false positive remove messages
in team
and escalate for investigation then you
have monitor and reports of
communication compliance dashboard
widgets export logs and event events
record
in the unified audit logs continually
evaluate and improve your compliance
posture
so there you go that's communication
compliance
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're looking at the concept of
information barriers so information
barriers are policies that admins can
configure
to prevent individuals or groups from
communicating with each other
so information barriers can be applied
to microsoft teams onedrive for business
sharepoint online and more
and information barriers only support
two-way restrictions so maybe a use case
would be like your school
but you don't want one student to see
the records of another student
or a lawyer cannot obtain client data
from another lawyer
so you know for microsoft teams
information barriers policies can
restrict the following searching for a
user
adding a member to a team starting a
chat session with someone
and starting with a group chat and
inviting someone to join a meeting
sharing a screen placing a phone call
sharing a file with another user
uh access to the file through sharing
links so there's a lot of
restrictions and that's great for
microsoft teams where you do this i
think it's in the m365 compliance center
i really tried hard to find this but
it's just like
this course like i can't find anything
but it's something you need to know
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at
privileged access management
so it protects your organization from
breaches and helps to meet compliance
best practices by limiting sand
limiting standing access to sensitive
data or access to critical configuration
settings so this gives you just-in-time
access rules
uh and there are uh that are implemented
for tasks that need
of elevated permissions and let an
organization operate with zero standing
access
enabling privileged access management
for um exchange online in microsoft 365
allows your organization to operate with
zero standing privileges
and provides a layer of defense against
standing administrative access
vulnerabilities
so here you can create approvers group
enable privileged access management
create an access policy submit approval
privilege access requests
and that's all the steps there if you
just want to see it there again okay
[Music]
so customer lockbox protects sensitive
data when working with microsoft support
engineers by enforcing a request
system to view custom private
information to resolve an
m365 related issue so customer lock box
supports requests to access data for
exchange online sharepoint online
onedrive for business
and you need to turn on customer lock
box in order for this uh to work
and the support engineer must make an
email request and a pr
and it must be approved by you before
they can access it and the support
engineer only has access for the minimum
amount of time
that they need it for and an audit trail
of access is maintained so that way
you know if there was tampering stuff
that evidence is there
so here is an example of a request that
is pending your approval so
the support engineer is saying hey i
need to get into
whatever it is and and you say accept or
deny okay
so there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look at e-discovery
and this is again
another service found within the m365
compliance center
so e-discovery stands for electronic
electronic discovery and this is the
process of identifying and delivering
electronic information that can be used
as evidence
in legal cases so e-discovery tools in
m365 to search content in
exchange online m365 groups and in teams
in sharepoint online onedrive for
business sites
skype for business conversations yammer
teams
and so there are two uh options we have
core in advance we'll definitely
walk through those two but m365 provides
the following e-discovery tools so
content search
core e-discovery advanced ediscovery
okay so we will
get into these now
[Music]
so core e-discovery in m365 provides a
basic e-discovery tool that
organizations can use to
search and export content in m365 and
office 365 so
you can use query discovery to place an
e-discovery hold
on content locations such as your
mailboxes
sharepoint onedrive and microsoft teams
so nothing is needed to deploy
query discovery but there are some
prerequisites that you have to do
uh before you can complete for your
organization okay so
those would be things like verifying and
assigning appropriate licensing
assign e-discovery permissions create a
core e-discovery case and then from
there
you can use the holds the search for
content and export and download the
search results okay
[Music]
let's take a closer look here at content
search and holds for e-discovery
workflows so
to perform a content search you can
create a new search
specify the locations provide keywords
and conditions and if you'll leave the
keywords blank it will return all the
items and conditions
i just want you to notice a few things
here you can also search by
id list here we have our location so we
have exchange point sharepoint exchange
i think teams is supposed to show up
there i'm not sure why it's not there
for my use case
you could also search within a hold so
you have your keyword you can leave that
blank and they have a lot of conditions
like i cut this off but it's like super
long
okay so then we have holds and so the
difference here is that a whole
will preserve content uh for as long as
the hold exists
okay and so you are being you're able to
basically search the exact same things
um with the exception i think yammer
groups is added there the con
is preserved until you remove the
content location from the hold or until
you delete the hold
after you create an e-discovery hold it
may take up to 24 hours for the hole to
take effect
okay
[Music]
so let's take a look here at advanced
e-discovery workflow so this workflow
builds on the existing
core discovery discovery workflow but
it's just a lot more advanced it's an
end-to-end workflow to preserve collect
review analyze
and export content that's relevant to
your organization's internal external
investigation
it also lets your legal teams manage the
entire legal hold notification workflow
to communicate with custodians involved
in a case so the built-in workflow for
advanced e-discovery just described
below
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at m365
audit
so what is an audit well that's an
investigation uh into a security event
forensic investigation
internal investigation or compliance
obligation an audit would involve
capturing recording retaining a unified
audit log
and uh m365 has two solutions so we have
a basic audit so enabled by default
thousands of searchable audit events
90-day audit record retention
expert audit records to a csv and this
tool shows up in the
compliance center it also comes with
the activity api so it's just a way of
interacting with it and you can also use
it in powershell with the
search unified audit log commandlet then
there are
is the uh advanced audit so this
includes all the base uh basic features
of audit features
um but it has retention policies longer
retention periods
high value and crucial events and higher
bandwidth
to the office 365 management activity
api
okay
[Music]
hey this is angie brown from exam pro
and we are taking a look at resource
locks
so as an admin you may need to lock a
subscription resource group or resource
to prevent other users from accidentally
deleting or modifying critical resources
so this is within azure here i have a
resource group
and i can set it either to read only and
so this will allow the authorized users
to
who can read a resource but they can't
delete or update the resource
and then you have the delete so
authorized users can still read and
modify resource
but they can't delete the resource if
you notice there's a bit of
inconsistency with the naming where i
have read only and cannot delete it's
because this is what they are in the api
and this is what they are in the actual
portal okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at resource tags
so a tag is a key and value pair that
you can assign to
azure resources so it's as simple as a
name and a value or a key and a value
and so some tag examples could be a
department so a status
a team an environment a project a
location
and so tags are really important because
they allow you to
filter your inventory in a lot of
different ways so they allow you to
organize
based on resource management so specific
workloads environments like developer
environments
maybe cost management and optimization
so cost tracking budgets alerts
operations management so business
commitments sla
operations mission uh critical services
security which is the one we're
interested in for this course so
a classification of data and security
impact governance and regulatory
compliance another one we care about
automation workflow automation okay
[Music]
let's take a look here at azure
blueprints and this enables quick
creation of governed subscription so
you can compose artifacts based on
common or organizational based patterns
into reusable blueprints the service is
designed to help with environment setup
so blueprints are a declarative way to
orchestrate the
deployment of various resource templates
and other artifacts such as role
assignments policy assignments
arm templates resource groups and so
azure blueprints
service is backed by the globally
distributed azure cosmodb
and blueprint objects are replicated to
multiple azure regions
a comparison is between arm templates
and blueprints because they appear to do
the same thing
and so nearly everything you'd want to
include for deployment in azure
blueprint
can be accomplished with an arm template
but with arm templates they are stored
either locally or in source control
there's no active connection or
relationship to the arm template
but with blueprints the relationship
between the blueprint definition what
should be deployed in the blueprint
assignment what
was deployed is a huge advantage here
especially if you are
care about this from the sense of
compliance or security
because then we have an exact idea what
is going on with their stuff so
you can also upgrade several
subscriptions at once that are governed
by the same blueprint
so azure blueprint supports improved
tracking and auditing
of deployment so that is the difference
there okay
[Music]
so azure policies enforces
organizational standards to assess
compliance at scale and policies do not
restrict access
but they only observe for compliance so
here's a list of
built-in policies that you use right
away and if you can squint here i know
it's a small screenshot
but do we see fedramp nist things like
that and notice that they map over to
they might map over to specific services
or maybe it's regulatory compliance it's
going to vary for that stuff okay
so the idea is that a policy is actually
just a policy definition and this is
just a json file
users describe business rules to control
access resources you have policy
assignments so this is the scope of a
policy
effect so it can be assigned to a user
resource group or management group
then you have policy parameters these
are values you can pass into a policy
definition
or so or or your policies are flexible
for reuse
then you have initiative definitions
this is an initial definition is a
collection of policy definitions
that can assign so let's say you want a
group of policies to enforce
pci uh dss compliance so notice here
the reason i have that arrow is because
we're looking at oops we're looking at
the policy type over here
so that's just these are all just one
policy definition files each of
these are a single file and then the
initiatives over here
these are a collection okay now in terms
of viewing non-compliant resources
once the policy is assigned it will
evaluate for the compliance state
periodically
so here you can see that we have a
compliance tab
and in this particular case this is the
policy that we
uh have here and we can see that it's
not being compliant okay
so it's not super complicated but there
you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at the
microsoft cloud adoption framework for
azure
and the idea behind this white paper and
i call it a white paper because that's
what it is even if it's in
this kind of website format but it's
here to
help organizations
utilize a step by step process
to migrate their workloads over to azure
so if you scroll on down here
i mean they describe all these
categories here but this is the visual
here so the idea is you're going to
define a strategy
you're going to create a plan you're
going to
get ready so ready would be setting up a
landing zone
then you'd have to adopt either by
migrating or innovating
and then up between these steps you're
going to govern and manage so
where does security fit in this well on
the left-hand side you'll notice there's
a whole section it's weird that it
doesn't show up in here
but there's a whole section on security
and so there's security and governance
and that's generally what we're
interested
in but if we just click into the secure
section uh you can see here
it talks about things in the security
disciplines like
risk insights security integrations
business resilience
and then the security disciplines that
we need to have if you scroll on down
and this is what i found the most useful
is that
this particular graph kind of shows you
the type of roles
uh in your community they're going to
need so like uh when
in the plan stage like who you're going
to need in your team in order to
fulfill this to the end right so i guess
you could say security
happens throughout the entire uh uh
cloud adoption framework but yeah you're
just going to need different kinds of
people to help you for different
sections okay
they do emphasize on three things like
the xero trust uh
model which we all know about uh i don't
know what open group is
the security disciplines map closely to
the zero trust components in the core
principles white paper
uh published by the open group where
microsoft actively participates
okay so it's space it's basically a
white paper another white paper
uh that is just more about uh zero trust
models
other than this cyber security framework
which is a pretty standardized framework
uh used across the board for all csps so
you know um you just need to know what
the cloud adoption framework is
it is uh pretty useful to go through and
read this but there's a lot of stuff
okay and so
we've covered a lot of this in the
course so um you know it's up to you if
you want to do it
it's definitely an auxiliary read but
there you go
[Music]
hey this is andrew brown from exam pro
and we're taking a look here at the
azure well architected framework
and this describes the best practices
for building workloads on azure
categorized into five pillars so we have
cost optimization
operational excellence performance
efficiency reliability and security
uh if you've ever seen the aws
well-arcade framework it's
pretty similar like the pillars are
one-to-one okay
so cost optimization is managing costs
to maximize the value delivered
operation processes that keep a system
running in production the ability of a
system to adapt changes in the load uh
reliability the ability of a system to
recover from failures and continue to
function
and the last pillar security protecting
applications and data from threats
so for the topics covered security
pillar we have
role of security security design
principles regulatory compliance
reduce organizational risk
administration application services
government risk and compliance identity
access management
network security and containment
security operations and there's a lot in
here and i actually went through all
of these categories and i did summaries
on them
uh but like it's just not fun to read
through all this stuff and i don't feel
that
uh the course is gonna test you on it
but i just wanted to show you that i
actually did do it i went through it all
um and so you know maybe i'll include
these in the downloadable
lecture notes so if you do want to go
through it and you just want a quick
summary of all these categories
but i just went through it to see if
there was something that seemed really
really
necessary uh but you know it's just it's
just information overload so i'm not
going to uh read through all this
because we'd be here for like 15-20
minutes uh but i just wanted to know
that that resource is
available to you and you might want to
just skim through it to you know get a
general sense of security in azure okay
[Music]
so the microsoft security best practices
is a collection of best practices that
provide clear actionable guidance for
security-related decisions
this was previously known as the azure
security compass
and so the best practices are packaged
into a series of videos
or you can download the powerpoint
slides and so the pr the best practice
covers the following governance risk
compliance
security operations identity and access
management network security containment
information protection and storage
application services
and this is about 150 slides now the
videos are pretty dull i wouldn't watch
them but the slides are amazing and i'm
definitely going to show you after this
video
we're gonna go take a peek at that uh
slideshow uh but you know there there's
the best practices the well architect
framework the cloud adoption framework
there's a lot of coverage that's in the
same place
i feel that this one this particular
resource should have been on
the exam guide uh but anyway i'm going
to show it to you because
you're just going to see you're going to
go wow i'm going to spend some time
reading here and it's going to probably
help you
solidify all the knowledge you've
learned in this course okay
all right so what i did here is i just
typed in microsoft security best
practices and
below you can see that there's these
guidance if you click into them
here's all the videos it would take
forever to watch these things and
they're really padded out they're just
talking way too much
but you know if you're looking to dive
in a particular section you can go in
there and check it out
really good auxiliary resource for this
course but i do cover everything so
it's not necessary but if you're
interested to do it
here you have a downloadable
presentational slide that is what i did
here
i just want to show you how much they've
done in this this is crazy
like you go through it and so a lot of
stuff we covered right but they just
have really great visuals for this stuff
and even stuff that we didn't covered so
but there's like a lot of slides like
i'm just going to click through here
just to show you what i'm talking about
a lot of these show up like you know the
responsibility model we covered that
uh these things i think i saw them in
the cloud adoption framework
so they're really pulling resources
everywhere and creating very strong
visuals for it
uh but again you know it's a little bit
overkill
um for um you know if this was the the
main study course material
but yeah just browse through it and see
what interests you okay
[Music]
hey it's andrew brown from exam pro and
we're taking a look here at shared
access signatures so
sas is a url that grants restricted
access rights to azure storage
the share uh you can share the uri to
grant
client temporary access to specific set
of permissions so
you have a few different types of access
signatures so account level sas so
access to resources in one or more
of the storage services service level
sas so access to the single storage
account by using the storage account key
user delegated sas these are access to
storage accounts using azure 80
credentials
limited only to blob and containers
microsoft considers this method the best
practice for accessing
via the sas so you know you use that one
if that's the case
a shared access signature comes in
different formats so you have ad hoc sas
the start time expiry time permissions
are part of the uri
any type of sas can be an ad hoc sas
then you have
service sas with stored access policies
a stored access policy is defined on a
resource container
limited to the blob container table cues
or file shares
the stored access policy can be
associated to multiple sas to manage
constraints
i know all these options seem really
confusing but that's just what it is
it's a lot more clear when you use it
because you're just checkboxing stuff
right
um so the uri format itself is the blob
uri
then there's the version number the
start time the expiration the storage
resources the permissions the signature
they're not going to ask you to identify
this stuff on the exam i'm just showing
you the structure of it because it's a
really long string and it's good to know
what it looks like
and yeah this is all those check boxes
i'm talking about so you just go in here
and you say i want to generate out a an
sas
you say what do i want it for what are
the resource types what's the lab
permissions
what's the time frame what protocol do i
want do i allow particular ips uh you
have your signing key and you generate
it and it's that simple
[Music]
so let's take a look here at cores which
stands for cross
origin resource sharing it is an http
header
based mechanism that allows a server to
indicate any other origins
so whether it be a domain a scheme a
report that it's owned
from which a browser should permit
loading of resources so you have a
website
and on your website you're going to have
a piece of content so maybe it is a
embedded script
and so the thing is where does that
script originate from so if it's from
the same domain that's con then it's
going to be
of same origin as the server now you
could also embed let's say an
image and that image could come from a
different domain and now it's
technically
cross origin and so unless you permit it
using a special header such as access
control allowed origin
it would be automatically blocked
because it's there to protect you right
so cores restricts which websites may
access data
to be loaded onto a page and so the way
it does that is through http headers
so you'll have request headers like
origin or access
control request method request headers
and for response you'd have access
control allowed origin credentials
headers
max age allowed methods and headers the
ones we see most common
it'll be this one here the origin so
where are you from i'm from domain one
and then for the headers it would be
like
what do you want to allow so here it's a
wild card but you could put in
uh uh like wildcard and then a domain
name you could put multiple domain names
in there to say these are the ones that
are allowed to embed things on my
website
or be able to be loaded on my particular
website
and you have methods that's a very
common one like is it allowed to do get
post put patch
options stuff like that okay
let's take a look here at the microsoft
security development lifecycle the sdl
and so this is an industry-leading
software security assurance process
and it's a microsoft-wide initiative and
a mandatory process since 2004
the sdl has played a critical role in
betting security and privacy in
microsoft software and culture
so building security into each stl phase
of development lifecycle helps you catch
issues earlier and it helps you reduce
your developer
development costs so this is all about
pushing left we talked about in security
it means
doing things a lot earlier and so it has
the face the phases of training
requirements design implementation
verification release response
probably won't show up your exam but
like you should know what stls are we
talking about security so i had to
include it in here okay